THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW WILL COME TO
ORDER. WE'RE HOLDING OUR HEARING
TODAY AT 1021 Þ STREET, ROOM
1200. I ASK THAT MEMBERS WHO ARE
AVAILABLE, PLEASE COME TO BE
PRESENT SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE ARE CURRENTLY TWO
MEMBERS SHORT. PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE HEARD. AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED, SO NOT AFTER EACH
INDIVIDUAL ITEM. OKAY. WE'RE AT
WE'RE ONE SHORT NOW. WE'LL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AS SOON AS WE
GET ONE MORE. SO I'M TRYING TO
SUMMON THE OTHER PERSON. OKAY,
GREAT. SENATOR LAIRD IS THE, IS
THE ENFORCER TODAY? OKAY, SO THE
BILLS THAT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
TODAY ARE AB 108, WHICH IS A
BUDGET BILL. JUNIOR FOR THE 2024
BUDGET ACT, AB 109, ALSO A
BUDGET BILL. JUNIOR REVISING THE
2023 BUDGET ACT. AND THEN 17
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS. TOGETHER
WITH AB 107, THE BUDGET ACT OF
2024, AND IN ADDITION TO TRAILER
BILLS SB 154 AND SB 167, WHICH
PASSED, LAST WEEK OR TWO WEEKS
AGO. LAST WEEK, THE BILLS BEFORE
US TODAY REPRESENT A BUDGET
AGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT INCLUDES $293 BILLION
IN TOTAL SPENDING. 211.5 BILLION
OF WHICH IS GENERAL FUND, THE
BUDGET IS BALANCED IN BOTH 20
2425 FISCAL YEAR. AND THE 20
2526 FISCAL YEAR. AND INCLUDES
OVER $46.8 BILLION IN SOLUTIONS
FOR THE 20 2425 FISCAL YEAR. DUE
TO MORE THAN A DECADE OF
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING AND
DESPITE THE CHALLENGES OF THE
CURRENT BUDGET, THE STATE WILL
MAINTAIN $22.2 BILLION IN
COMBINED RESERVES FOR FUTURE
YEARS, HIGHLIGHTS OF THE FINAL
BUDGET PACKAGE INCLUDE INCREASED
FUNDING FOR K THROUGH 14
SCHOOLS. FUNDING PROP 98 AT
NEARLY $2 BILLION, MORE THAN THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSED, AND A
DEPOSIT OF 1.1 BILLION INTO THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT, THE
BUDGET RESTORES PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS TO CORE PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING CALWORKS FOSTER CARE
AND IN-HOME SUPPORT SERVICES.
THE BUDGET RETAINS MORE THAN
11,000 ALREADY AWARDED
ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE SLOTS AND
REDUCES THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
ONE YEAR DELAY OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES RATE INCREASES TO A SIX
MONTH DELAY. SO INSTEAD OF A ONE
YEAR DELAY, AND MAINTAINS
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS, THE
BUDGET REDUCES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
BUDGET BY APPROXIMATELY $750
MILLION. IT PROTECTS MANY
CLIMATE RELATED PRIORITIES, SUCH
AS OFFSHORE WIND BUILDING,
DECARBONIZATION, AND ENERGY
RELIABILITY PROGRAMS, THE BUDGET
REJECTS THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO PERMANENTLY
ELIMINATE MORE THAN $2.4 BILLION
IN ANNUAL NEW HEALTH INVESTMENTS
SCHEDULED TO TAKE EFFECT JANUARY
1ST, AND INSTEAD TARGETED NEW
INVESTMENTS WILL START JANUARY
1ST, 2025, WITH OTHERS STARTING
THE FOLLOWING JANUARY 1ST. THE
BUDGET PROVIDES $1 BILLION FOR
THE HOMELESS, HOUSING AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM. HAP. ROUND
SIX. COLLEAGUES, THIS IS A
BUDGET TO BE PROUD OF. IT
INCLUDES REAL AND LASTING
SOLUTIONS TO BALANCE THE BUDGET
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS. WHILE
PROTECTING THE PROGRESS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE ON CORE
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT OUR
RESIDENTS. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO WORKED SO HARD ALL
YEAR TO PREPARE THIS BUDGET,
INCLUDING OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY, CHAIR GABRIEL IN
PARTICULAR, THE ADMINISTRATION,
OUR BUDGET STAFF, AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE, SO
AGAIN, AFTER HEARING ALL OF THE
BILLS, WE WILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT BEFORE VOTING. AND NOW,
MISTER VICE CHAIR, DO YOU HAVE
ANY OPENING COMMENTS, THANK YOU,
MISTER CHAIR. I APPRECIATE THAT,
PROBABLY WILL NOT COME AS A
TERRIBLE SURPRISE TO YOU THAT I
DON'T ENDORSE EVERYTHING THAT
YOU JUST SAID BY WAY OF
INTRODUCTION, THERE THERE ARE
SOME PIECES OF THIS BUDGET THAT
ARE SUPPORTABLE AND WILL, SEE
THAT AS THE HEARING MOVES ON.
BUT MUCH OF IT IS NOT, AS I HAVE
SAID BEFORE, WITHOUT GOING INTO
A LOT OF DETAIL, THE BUDGET IS,
NOMINALLY BALANCED. OF COURSE,
IT HAS TO BE, BUT IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE. I BELIEVE FIRMLY
THAT THE JANUARY, PROPOSAL OF
THE GOVERNORS IN 2025 WILL, BE
FACING A LARGER DEFICITS THAN
THE, I THINK, ROUGHLY 10 BILLION
WERE ANTICIPATING. AND OF
COURSE, WE REPUBLICANS HAD, VERY
LITTLE TO DO WITH THIS FINAL
PRODUCT. AND, THE REALITY OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS THAT
WHETHER REQUIRED OR NOT, A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT, BOTH THE MAJORITY
VIEWS AS WELL AS THE MINORITY
REVIEWS, VIEWS, AGAIN, WHETHER
REQUIRED OR NOT, A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH, AT LEAST CONSIDERING,
THE VIEWS OF ALL SIDES USUALLY
ENDS UP WITH A MORE SUSTAINABLE
LEGISLATIVE OR IN THIS CASE,
BUDGET PRODUCT. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION.
AND, LET'S GET ON WITH IT. OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. VICE
CHAIR. WE MAY HAVE A QUORUM.
THREE, FOUR, FIVE. SIX. OH. HE'S
LEAVING. OKAY. NO, I'M KIDDING.
WE HAVE QUORUM, I BELIEVE,
RIGHT? YES. OKAY, GREAT. LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SENATORS
WIENER PRESENT NHIÀU HERE.
BECKER. LAKESPUR PRESENT.
CORTEZ. HERE. DALI HERE. DEROSA.
BERGMAN GROVE. LAIRD HERE.
MENGIBAR NEWMAN. PADILLA ROTH.
HERE. SATO HERE. SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WAHAB. WILK
HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY, WE HAVE A
QUORUM. OKAY. I'M NOW GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO ERICA LEE. CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, FOR AN
OVERVIEW OF THE BILLS BEFORE US
TODAY. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
WIENER. VICE CHAIR NILO. MEMBERS
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE, ERICA
LEE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND I AM PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ON THE 20
2425 BUDGET AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION, THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY. THIS
AGREEMENT, IMPORTANTLY, PUTS THE
STATE ON A MORE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE, LONG TERM PATH THAT
PROTECTS CORE PROGRAMS,
ASSISTING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. THE AGREEMENT
MAINTAINS THE MULTI-YEAR
STRUCTURE THAT WAS INTRODUCED IN
THE MAY REVISION IT SOLVES FOR
BUDGET DEFICITS IN THE BUDGET
WINDOW AND THE FISCAL YEAR THAT
FOLLOWS 20 2526. BEYOND THIS
MULTI YEAR STRUCTURE, THE
AGREEMENT ALSO INCLUDES FURTHER
BUDGET RESILIENCE AND MAINTAINS
A HEALTHY RESERVE AS WAS
MENTIONED BY THE CHAIR. WHILE IT
DOES ASSUME WITHDRAWALS FROM THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT OR
THE RAINY DAY FUND OVER THE NEXT
TWO FISCAL YEARS, 5.1 BILLION IN
BUDGET YEAR AND 7.1 BILLION IN
2526, THERE IS OVER 22 BILLION
IN TOTAL RESERVES REMAINING AT
THE END OF THE BUDGET, FISCAL
YEAR. AT THE END OF THE 2425
FISCAL YEAR. ADDITIONALLY THE
AGREEMENT INCLUDES LEGISLATION
REQUIRING THE STATE TO SET ASIDE
A PORTION OF ANTICIPATED SURPLUS
FUNDS TO BE ALLOCATED IN A
SUBSEQUENT BUDGET ACT ONLY AFTER
THOSE REVENUES HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN RECEIVED, SOME TOP LINE
NUMBERS. THE AGREEMENT INCLUDES
TOTAL EXPENDITURES OF 297.9
BILLION. ALL FUNDS, OF WHICH
211.5 BILLION IS A GENERAL FUND.
THE STATE FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY IS BALANCED OVER THE
NEXT TWO FISCAL YEARS, WITH
POSITIVE BALANCES OF 3.5 BILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND 1.5
BILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR, PLUS
ONE. AND AS MENTIONED, THE
RESERVES REMAINING AFTER THIS
AGREEMENT, AFTER THIS BUDGET
YEAR, INCLUDE OVER $22 BILLION.
THE AGREEMENT FUNDS THE PROP 98
MINIMUM GUARANTEE AT 115.3
BILLION, OF WHICH 82.6 BILLION
IS GENERAL FUND. FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR FOR PRE-K THROUGH 12
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
MAINTAINING EDUCATION PROGRAMS
AND MITIGATING REDUCTIONS IN THE
CLASSROOM. THE AGREEMENT SOLVES
A $46.8 BILLION DEFICIT FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR, THAT IS HIGHER THAN
THE MAY REVISION SLIGHTLY
BECAUSE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH OUR PROP 98 AND IMPACTS OF
NOL. SPECIFICALLY, WE HAVE
CATEGORIES OF, 2.1 BILLION IN
DEFERRALS, 3.1 BILLION IN PAUSES
AND DELAYS, 5.9 OR 6 BILLION IN
FUND SHIFTS, ANOTHER 6 BILLION
IN RESERVES, 13.6 BILLION IN
REVENUE AND BORROWING AND THEN
LASTLY, THE LARGEST NUMBER, 16
BILLION IN REDUCTIONS.
IMPORTANTLY, THE AGREEMENT DOES
MAINTAIN CORE PROGRAMS THAT
SERVE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS,
AGAIN, PROP 98 PROTECTS
EDUCATION NOW AND INTO THE
FUTURE. THIS BUDGET MAINTAINS OR
THIS AGREEMENT MAINTAINS FUNDING
FOR THE EXPANSION OF HEALTH CARE
TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS, REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND INCLUSIVE
OF IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES,
IT MAINTAINS THE 9.2% STATE
SUPPLEMENT PAYMENT, WHICH IS
PART OF THE SSI SSP BASE GRANT.
IT MAINTAINS A CUMULATIVE 31.3%
BASE INCREASE IN CALWORKS
MAXIMUM MAXIMUM AID PAYMENTS,
SINCE 2021. THE AGREEMENT ALSO
IDENTIFIES CONTINUED INVESTMENTS
IN VITAL PROGRAMS, THERE IS
1,000,000,001 TIME TO PROVIDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FUNDING TO
COMBAT THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS,
AND THIS IS TIED TO INCREASED
ACCOUNTABILITY. AS WAS DISCUSSED
IN A PREVIOUS HEARING HERE,
THERE'S 250 MILLION FOR
ENCAMPMENT GRANTS, ALONG WITH
ADDITIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND REPORTING.
THERE IS 103,000,001 TIME FOR
VICTIMS ASSISTANCE GRANTS AND 80
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR TWO YEARS
FOR THE NONPROFIT SECURITY
GRANTS. NOW THAT WAS JUST A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT. AND I WILL BRIEFLY
REVIEW THE RELATED BUDGET BILL,
JUNIORS AND TRAILER BILLS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE 2425 BUDGET
AGREEMENT, ENSURE WIENER WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO DO, GO THROUGH
EACH BILL INDIVIDUALLY AND THEN
HAVE QUESTIONS OR READ THROUGH
ALL 19 BILLS, MAYBE JUST BRIEFLY
GO THROUGH THEM? OKAY, IF UNLESS
YOU THINK THAT'S I'M PREPARED TO
DO THAT AND WELL, WHY DON'T WE
ACTUALLY WHY DON'T WE INSTEAD OF
DOING THAT LET'S START. LET'S DO
LEAVE IT FOR QUESTIONS, OKAY?
WHAT PEOPLE ARE, ARE INTERESTED
IN. YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY, MR. PADDOCK, ANYTHING TO
THE LÀ WOULD LIKE TO ADD CHAIR.
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS. GOOD
MORNING. WE ARE HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. YES. THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
COLLEAGUES, IF THERE ARE ANY
INITIAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
NOW'S A GOOD TIME. ANYONE I
THINK KEVIN COULD GO THROUGH ALL
THE STUFF. OKAY. YOU PREFER
THAT? YEAH. YEAH, I THINK SO. I
THINK WE JUST GO THROUGH ALL OF
THEIR PRESENTATION IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT COMES ALONG THE
WAY, I THINK A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ASKED, AND IT'S NOT I DON'T
THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
ANYTHING THAT IS GOING TO BE
CHANGING ANYTHING IN THE BUDGET.
SO I THINK THAT WOULD BE FINE TO
HAVE THEM GO THROUGH THE WHOLE
THING. OKAY. I MEAN, WHY DON'T
WE JUST GO FOR THE BUDGET
TRAILER? BILL'S NOT IN
EXCRUCIATING DETAIL, THAT'S ALL
VERY PUBLIC ALREADY AND THESE
BILLS, BUT I KIND OF LIKE
EXCRUCIATING DETAIL. AND THEN TO
GO THROUGH AT A HIGH LEVEL AND
THEN MEMBERS CAN ASK SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT TRAILER BILLS,
TO DIG IN. SO BASED ON MEMBER
INTERESTS. SO IF YOU WANT TO
JUST AT A HIGH LEVEL, OKAY, I
WILL CONDENSE SOME OF MY
PREPARED REMARKS, THE FIRST,
BILL IS AB, SB 108, WHICH IS A
BUDGET BILL, JR, THAT AMENDS THE
2024 BUDGET ACT. AND THIS BILL
INCLUDES MULTIPLE, OF OUR
SOLUTIONS, INCLUDING REDUCTIONS,
AS WELL AS FUND SHIFTS, THERE
ARE SOME DELAYS IN HERE AS WELL,
ONE HIGHLIGHT THAT I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT, BECAUSE IT WAS THE
SUBJECT OF SEVERAL OF
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD IN THE
PRIOR HEARING, IS THE REDUCTION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION, THEIR
BUDGET. THIS INCLUDES 750
MILLION GENERAL FUND REDUCTION,
WHICH IS ABOUT 392 MILLION, IS
ASSOCIATED WITH A STATEWIDE
REDUCTIONS FOR VACANT POSITION
AND FUNDING SWEEP AS WELL AS
STATE OPERATIONS, SO I KNOW THAT
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
DISCUSSED AT LENGTH. AND SO I
WANT TO POINT THAT OUT. THIS
ALSO INCLUDES SOME REDUCTIONS TO
HOUSING, AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SHIFTS FOR TRANSPORTATION,
DELAYS IN BROADBAND. OKAY,
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT BILL, AB,
SB 109. THIS IS A BUDGET BILL,
JUNIOR, THAT AMENDS THE 2023
BUDGET ACT. AND LARGELY THIS
BILL MAKES TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE 2023
BUDGET ACT. THE NEXT BILL IS AB,
SB 153, WHICH IS THE K THROUGH
12 EDUCATION, AND THIS BILL
INCLUDES DEFERRAL, RESERVE
WITHDRAWALS AND ACCRUALS AS PART
OF THE PROP 98 AGREEMENT. ONE
OTHER THING I WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION IS THIS, SUSPENDS THE
AUGUST 15TH, 2024 LAYOFF WINDOW
FOR TEACHERS. OTHER NON
ADMINISTRATIVE CERTIFICATED
STAFF AS WELL AS CLASSIFIED
STAFF. MOVING ON TO AB, SB 155.
THIS IS THE HIGHER EDUCATION
BILL. LIKE THE PREVIOUS BILL IT
INCLUDES DEFERRAL RESERVE
WITHDRAWALS AND ACCRUALS AS PART
OF THE PROP 98 AGREEMENT AND
THIS TIME FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, AND IT ESTABLISHES A
STUDENT HOUSING LEASE REVENUE
BOND STRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS. MOVING ON TO AB. SB
159, THIS IS THE HEALTH TRAILER
BILL. AND THIS BILL INCLUDES A
TRIGGER REGARDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HEALTH
CARE WORKER. MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE. IT EXEMPTS STATE
FACILITIES AND MAKES OTHER
IMPLEMENTATION CLARIFICATIONS.
THIS ALSO EFFECTUATES THE NEW
TARGETED MEDI-CAL PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES AND INVESTMENTS FROM
THE MCO TAX, INCLUDING PHYSICIAN
SERVICES, EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
SERVICES, AND SEVERAL OTHERS. IT
ESTABLISHES THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL DIRECTED PAYMENT
PROGRAM AND EXPANDS ELIGIBILITY
FOR AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE, OR
ADAP. MOVING ON TO AB, SB 160.
THIS IS THE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION OR MCO TAX TRAILER
BILL, AND THIS BILL INCLUDES AN
INCREASE TO THE MCO TAX STATE
FUNDING TO ACHIEVE ADDITIONAL
NET STATE BENEFIT BEYOND THE
BENEFIT THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR THE EARLY
ACTION. THIS IS A NEARLY 1.8
BILLION ADDITIONAL REVENUE IN
2425, 1.9 BILLION IN 2526, AND
1.4 BILLION IN 2627. THE NEXT
BILL IS AB, SB 161, THE BILL ON
HUMAN TRAILER BILL AND HUMAN
SERVICES. THIS BILL IMPLEMENTS
THE ESTABLISHES A PERMANENT RATE
STRUCTURE FOR FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENTS THAT FOCUSES ON THE
CHILD'S INDIVIDUAL LEVEL OF NEED
AND STRENGTH, RATHER THAN THE
PLACEMENT TYPE, IT AUTHORIZES A
0.3% MAXIMUM AID PAYMENT FOR
CALWORKS, AND IT DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
APPLY FOR FEDERAL PROJECTS FOR
PROMOTING ACCOUNTABILITY BY
MEASURING WORK OUTCOMES. PILOT.
THIS IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CALWORKS PROGRAM. MOVING ON TO
AB. SB 162, THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TRAILER BILL. THIS BILL
DELAYS THE NEXT STEP IN SERVICE
PROVIDER RATE REFORM BY SIX
MONTHS. BUT IT DOES MAINTAIN THE
MOMENTUM IN DRIVING TOWARD AN
OUTCOMES FOCUSED SYSTEM, IT ALSO
, IT REPEALS THE PREVIOUSLY
SUSPENDED FAMILY COST
PARTICIPATION PROGRAM AND ANNUAL
FAMILY PROGRAM FEE, WHICH HAS
LARGELY BEEN SUSPENDED. MOVING
ON TO AB, SB 163, THE EARLY
LEARNING AND CHILD CARE TRAILER
BILL, THIS BILL CODIFIES
LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO ADD
ADDITIONAL STATE SUBSIDIZED
CHILD CARE SLOTS, AND IT
ESTABLISHES NEW PARAMETERS FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY FOR
STATE SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE
PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT RATES,
MOVING ON TO AB, SB 164, THIS
BILL, MOVES PROGRAMS OUT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH, OR OPR, TO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO REALIGN THE
DEPARTMENT WITH ITS CORE MISSION
AND RENAMES IT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF LAND USE AND CLIMATE
INNOVATION, IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY WITH A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR, IN DEVELOPING AND
CONSTRUCTING A STATEWIDE OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND
NETWORK TO WORK WITH LAST MILE
GRANT PROJECT AWARDEES, THE NEXT
BILL AB SB 166, IS THE HOUSING
TRAILER BILL, AND THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES AROUND SIX OF THE
HOMELESS HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM, OR HEP, TO
PROVIDE 1 BILLION TO CITIES,
COUNTIES, CONTINUUMS OF CARE AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS. AND AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER, IT INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. IT ALSO
ESTABLISHES ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE ENCAMPMENT
RESOLUTION GRANTS AB, SB 168,
THE TRAILER BILL, AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. IT ADJUSTS ALLOCATIONS
TO COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
BY 5.5% ON A ONE TIME BASIS TO
PROVIDE AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND GUARANTEES A
MINIMUM LEVEL OF FUNDING OF
200,000 FOR EACH COUNTY THAT
FALLS BELOW THIS AMOUNT, IT ALSO
MAKES AN APPROPRIATION OF 160
MILLION TO COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS FOR THE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM PURSUANT TO SB
678, AB. SB 169, THE TRAILER
BILL AND JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
EFFECTUATES THE TRANSFER OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE GRANT
ADMINISTRATION FUNCTIONS FROM
THE BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS TO THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION,
OR CR, AND IT EXTENDS AND
EXPANDS AN EXISTING REQUIREMENT
FOR COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
TO REPORT JUVENILE DATA TO OCR,
AS WAS ESTABLISHED IN STATUTE.
OKAY. MOVING ON TO AB. SB 170,
THE COURTS, THIS BILL EXTENDS
THE SUNSET DATES FOR REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS FOR CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL CASES THROUGH JANUARY 1ST
OF 2027, AND IT ALLOWS HABEAS
CORPUS RESOURCE CENTER ATTORNEYS
TO CONTINUE TO REPRESENT THEIR
CLIENTS WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
SENTENCED TO DEATH, BUT WHOSE
SENTENCES WERE REDUCED TO LIFE
WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE UNTIL JULY 1ST OF 2029.
AB. SB 171 IS THE LABOR TRAILER
BILL, AND THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO UTILIZE EMERGENCY
HIRING AUTHORITY TO EXPEDITE
HIRING AND FILL VACANCIES TO
INCREASE THE EFFECTIVE AND
TIMELY ENFORCEMENT OF EMPLOYEE
LABOR CLAIMS. IT ALSO CLARIFIES
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION APPEALS BOARD HAS
TO MAKE A FINAL DECISION ON AN
APPEAL. IT ALSO AUTHORIZES THE
DEFERRAL OF STATE EMPLOYEE
PAYROLL COSTS FROM JUNE 2025 TO
JULY 2025, AND INCLUDES 1.5
MILLION IN PROP TWO DEBT
REPAYMENT FUNDING FOR RETIREMENT
LIABILITIES, INCLUDING OTHER
POST-EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS OR
OPEB. THE AB. SB 173 IS A
TRAILER BILL ON TRANSPORTATION,
AND THIS BILL ADDS TO THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL PROVISIONS. IT
CLARIFIES COMPONENTS OF THE
EBONY ALERT PROCESS AND MAKES
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS SO THAT THE
TRANSIT ACCOUNTABILITY
PROVISIONS PUT IN PLACE AS PART
OF THIS YEAR'S BUDGET APPLY TO
ALL YEARS AND ALL FUND SOURCES
FOR THE FORMULA TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM
AND ZERO EMISSION TRANSIT
CAPITAL PROGRAM, AND MOVING ON
TO AB, SB, 174, WHICH IS THE
TRAILER BILL AND SEQUA. THIS
BILL PROVIDES GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS TOTALING 700
MILLION OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS TO FUND THE CAPITAL ANNEX
PROJECTS. IT EXEMPTS THE CAPITAL
ANNEX PROJECTS FROM THE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ACT, AND IT EXTENDS THE EXISTING
ACT. STATUTORY EXEMPTION FOR
SPECIFIED FISH AND WILDLIFE
RESTORATION PROJECTS BY FIVE
YEARS TO 20TH JANUARY ONE, 2030.
AND FINALLY, THE LAST TRAILER
BILL AB, SB 175 ON TAXATION.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A
REFUNDABILITY PROGRAM TO ENSURE
TAXPAYERS SUBJECT TO THE
BUSINESS CREDIT LIMITATION
PROPOSED BY AB. SB ONE 167 FOR
TAX YEARS 24, 25 AND 26 CAN
FULLY UTILIZE THEIR CREDITS
AFTER THE LIMITATION PERIOD
ENDS. IT ALSO IMPLEMENTS A
TRIGGER MECHANISM FOR TAX YEARS
2025 AND 2026, SUCH THAT CREDIT
LIMITATION AND NOL SUSPENSION
WILL NOT BE IN EFFECT FOR EACH
OF THOSE YEARS. IF REVENUES ARE
SUFFICIENT WITHOUT THE REVENUE
IMPACT FROM THE SOLUTION AS
DETERMINED BY THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE AT THE MAYOR'S VISION.
AND OF COURSE, PURSUANT TO
LEGISLATION IN THE ANNUAL BUDGET
ACT. AND WITH THAT, COMPLETES MY
BRIEF NOTES. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, COLLEAGUES. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
POINT? YES. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
SALADO. ALL RIGHT. WHAT DO YOU
WANT TO REPORT? WE DID ALREADY.
WE WOULDN'T YOU WE'RE THERE,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU GUYS,
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK ON,
TRYING TO MAKE THESE ADJUSTMENTS
AND TRYING TO MAKE THIS BALANCE
OVER THE YEAR. WE DO TRULY
APPRECIATE IT, THERE'S YOU KNOW,
WHENEVER WE DO THIS, PEOPLE
START TO THINK THAT THEY TAKE IT
PERSONALLY IF WE DON'T LIKE,
SOME ASPECTS OF THE BUDGET. THE
FIRST QUESTION I HAVE ON THE
CDCR, REDUCTIONS, WHAT IS THE
TOTAL AMOUNT BEING REDUCED OUT
OF CDCR? WHAT EXACTLY ARE WE
LOSING, IN TERMS OF SERVICE FROM
CDCR? SURE. THE TOTAL REDUCTIONS
ARE 750 MILLION. GENERAL FUND,
AND ON TOP OF THAT, THERE'S ALSO
82 MILLION FOR THE DEACTIVATION
OF HOUSING UNITS, SO THAT PUTS
US OVER 800, ABOUT 830 MILLION.
AND I'M JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE
WHO, CAN RESPOND AS WELL. HI.
KIMBERLY HARBISON, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, AS MISS LEE SAID, IT'S
392 MILLION FOR THE STATEWIDE
REDUCTIONS, WHICH INCLUDES THE
POSITION, THE VACANT POSITION,
MONEY THAT WILL TAKE FOR THOSE
POSITIONS AND THE STATEWIDE
REDUCTIONS. AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER, 358 MILLION FOR
SOLUTIONS THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND OTHER
THINGS, AND THEN WE'LL DETERMINE
OVER THE SUMMER AND INTO THE
FALL HOW TO ACHIEVE THE TOTAL
SAVINGS FOR THE STATEWIDE
REDUCTION. BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
CDCR AND THE NEED TO, MOLD IT
INTO WHAT WE WANT IT TO BE. AND
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME
TREMENDOUS INVESTMENT IN THE
FUTURE. AND IT SEEMS LIKE WE
KEEP GOING BACKWARDS BASED ON
HOPING WE DON'T HAVE AS MANY
CUSTOMERS FOR CDCR AND YET AS WE
ELIMINATE POSITIONS DOING THIS,
AND WE'RE ALL NOW WE'RE FOCUSED
ON SOME ADDITIONAL, PUBLIC
SAFETY, CRIME PREVENTION
MEASURES THAT INCLUDE, PROBABLY
PEOPLE GOING TO, TO, TO PRISON,
IT MY CONCERN IS THAT WE ARE NOT
WORKING CLOSELY ENOUGH WITH
CDCR, TO ENABLE THEM TO DO THEIR
JOB THE RIGHT WAY. AND WE'RE
MAKING, CUTS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO ADD BACK LATER, WHEN AND
ALSO, YOU KNOW, THOSE ARE JOBS.
AND WE TALK ABOUT ADDING JOBS IN
THIS STATE ALL THE TIME. AND YET
IN THIS PARTICULAR RESPECT,
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
ELIMINATE THEM. SO THAT'S A
CONCERN TO ME, SECOND QUESTION I
HAVE IS ABOUT THE, STUDENT
HOUSING LEASE REVENUE BONDS. IS
THIS THE WAY WE HAVE DONE
STUDENT HOUSING IN THE PAST, OR
HAVE WE PAID FOR STUDENT HOUSING
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY CONTROL
THE COST? BECAUSE WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH LEASE REVENUE
BONDS RIGHT NOW IS THEY GET
THOSE BOND PAYMENTS AND WHATEVER
ELSE THEY NEED FROM THE
STUDENTS, AND SO IN SOME CASES,
STUDENT HOUSING, ASSOCIATED WITH
SOME OF OUR UC'S, HAS GONE UP
$1,000 A MONTH THIS LAST YEAR, A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH. SO
THEY ARE ALMOST AT THE AT MARKET
PRICE. THAT'S NOT WHAT WE
ENVISION FOR STUDENT HOUSING. SO
MOVING IT INTO A LEASE REVENUE
BOND INSTEAD OF JUST USING MONEY
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND TO PAY
FOR THOSE, IS SETTING OUR
STUDENTS UP FOR FAILURE BECAUSE
THEN THEY'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
LARGER LOANS TO PAY FOR THOSE
THEIR, THEIR, HOUSING AND
EVENTUALLY, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE,
THEY'RE ADDING ON TO LOAN DEBT
THAT WE ALREADY ARE HAVING
STRUGGLES WITH. SO, IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE, THINKING
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO IS
TAKE OUT LEASE REVENUE BONDS?
SALLY LUCKENBILL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO THIS IS REALLY JUST,
COVERS A CERTAIN NUMBER OF,
PROJECTS THAT ARE HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ALLOCATED FUNDS THROUGH ED
CODE 17 201, JUST AS A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND, IN 2023, THE
LEGISLATURE AMENDED ED CODE 17
201 TO REQUIRE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, WHICH HAD RECEIVED
ALLOCATIONS THROUGH THE HIGHER
ED STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM, TO RETURN THEIR GENERAL
FUND ALLOCATIONS, AS PART OF A
GENERAL FUND SOLUTION, AND IN
ADDITION, ED CODE WAS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE INTENT LANGUAGE STATING
THAT NO LATER THAN THE 2024
BUDGET ACT, STATEWIDE LEASE
REVENUE OR OTHER FINANCING
PROGRAM WOULD BE ESTABLISHED TO
AWARD OR TO ALLOW THOSE PROJECTS
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE USE OF
LEASE REVENUE BONDS. SO IT'S
JUST A SMALL IT'S A IT'S 13
CAMPUSES, WE DO NOT EXPECT THIS
IS GOING TO BE A LONG TERM
SOLUTION FOR HOUSING, MY, MY,
COLLEAGUE, ON THE OUR SUPPORT
BUDGET CAN CAN ANSWER MORE
QUESTIONS ON THAT IF NECESSARY.
SO THIS ISN'T THIS IS BASICALLY
TAKING WHAT WE HAD, CUTTING THAT
AND THEN REPLACING IT WITH A
LOAN INSTEAD. YES. SO THAT'S A
THAT'S A WAY WE'RE BALANCING.
WELL, WE'RE BORROWING MONEY TO
BALANCE A CUT. WELL IT'S NOT A
LOAN WE WOULD PROVIDE INTERIM
LOANS DURING THE CONSTRUCTION
PERIOD. BUT THEN BONDS WOULD BE
SOLD AT THE RIGHT. I UNDERSTAND
THE BOND PROCESS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I APPRECIATE YOUR
EXPLANATION ON THAT, I THINK WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE MCO TAX AD
NAUSEAM, AND, YOU KNOW,
ESSENTIALLY THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK, WE NEED TO GET
BACK ON TRACK AS SOON AS WE CAN,
IT WAS SOLD AS A WAY OF HELPING
OFFSET, MEDI-CAL COSTS. AND
THOSE ARE GOING UP, NOT DOWN FOR
PROVIDERS. AND THE MORE IT GOES
UP WITHOUT US REIMBURSING OR
RAISING THAT REIMBURSEMENT, THIS
THE BIGGER THE STRUGGLE IS GOING
TO BE TO KEEP ENGAGING THOSE
PROVIDERS, IN OFFERING THAT THAT
HELP OR OFFERING THE MEDICAL
CARE TO PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
MEDI-CAL. SO, YEAH, THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT CONCERNS ME A
GREAT DEAL, THE SEQUA, AS YOU
CAN SEE, WE'RE ALREADY GETTING
DOWN TO THE END, SO IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE A WHOLE BAD PROCESS.
SEQUA, ON OUR AFFECTING ANNEX,
HOW IS THE SEQUA PROCESS? WHAT'S
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE ANNEX
THAT SEQUA IS AFFECTING IT? I'M
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE SALLY,
AGAIN, FOR SOME. OKAY. SORRY, I
DIDN'T MEAN TO MAKE YOU. YEAH.
CHANGE THAT'S NO PROBLEM. ONE
WAS A COMMENT. I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT, SO YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTION
ABOUT SEQUA. YEAH. WHAT'S
HOLDING UP? WHAT'S WHAT IN SEQUA
IS HOLDING UP OUR ANNEX THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE A CARVE OUT FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO EXEMPT IT FROM
SEQUA. WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THAT, WELL, THE SEQUA SEQUA HAS
ALREADY BEEN COMPLETED, FOR THE
PROJECT. AND IN FACT, THERE WAS
A ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT
THAT WAS, COMPLETED AND
CERTIFIED. AND THEN THERE WAS
ALSO A REVISED ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT THAT WAS, THAT WAS
ALSO CERTIFIED. AND THOSE WERE
IN RESPONSE. THE SECOND ONE WAS
IN RESPONSE TO A LEGAL
CHALLENGE, NOW, YOU KNOW, ALL OF
THE MAJOR MILESTONES HAVE
ALREADY BEEN, REVIEWED AND ALL
THE MAJOR, ISSUES THAT THAT HAVE
COME UP HAVE BEEN ASSESSED RIGHT
NOW. THERE'S A LOSS. THERE ARE,
I THINK, AT LEAST ONE LAWSUIT
THAT IS THREATENING TO STOP THE
PROJECT FOR A PERIOD OF TIME.
AND THAT'S VERY EXPENSIVE, ON A
PROJECT OF THAT SIZE, PROBABLY 5
MILLION A MONTH. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. THAT, TAKE THAT
STATEMENT YOU JUST MADE AND
APPLY THAT TO OUR ENTIRE STATE.
AND ALL THE PEOPLE DOING WORK
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY SEQUA. AND
THAT'S MY POINT WITH THIS, IS
IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE. IF WE DON'T
FIX SEQUA, AND I THINK WE HAVE
TO TAKE A BIGGER APPROACH, I SEE
I KNOW YOU WANT TO GET ON THAT
BUTTON AND CORRECT ME, BUT WE
HAVE TO TAKE A BETTER APPROACH,
WITH NOT JUST OUR ANNEX
BUILDING, BECAUSE IT IS IT'S
COSTING US A FORTUNE BECAUSE OF
THESE LAWSUITS. THAT'S THE PART
THAT'S THAT'S COSTING US A
FORTUNE. SO THAT JUST POINTS
THAT IN THE FUTURE WE NEED TO
WORK ON THIS SO THAT IT DOESN'T
AFFECT NOT ONLY US, BUT
EVERYBODY ELSE IN CALIFORNIA HAS
TO DEAL WITH THIS SEQUA LAW. WE
HAVE A LOT OF CEQA EXEMPTIONS
THIS YEAR. SO ANYWAY, I'M GOING
TO STOP THERE. I CAN SEE I'M
MAKING THE CHAIR NERVOUS. SO, I
SEE YOUR HAND GOING UP TO THE
BUTTON, AND SO I WANT TO CUT
MYSELF OFF. THANK YOU. YOU CAN
YOU CAN SAY WHATEVER YOU NEED TO
SAY, SENATOR. I APPRECIATE IT.
AND, SENATOR, I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT, I, I KNOW THERE YOU KNOW,
THERE WILL BE A NARRATIVE WHILE
WE'RE DOING THIS FOR THE, FOR
THE ANNEX, WHICH WE'VE DONE THE
FULL EIR FOR, BY THE WAY, AND WE
HAVE, THIS IS THE SITUATION HERE
IS ACTUALLY, IT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT FRUSTRATES ALL OF US
ABOUT SEQUA THAT SEQUA IS BEING
USED FOR REASONS THAT HAVE
LITERALLY NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT, TO STOP A PROJECT
AND TO ESCALATE COSTS FOR
TAXPAYERS. AND OF COURSE, AS YOU
KNOW, I'VE DONE I'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK AUTHORING SCHOOL
EXEMPTIONS, HAVING NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE ANNEX, AND ALSO
REMOVING A LOT OF HOUSING FROM
SEQUA ENTIRELY, AND I FULLY
AGREE THAT SEQUA NEEDS A BROAD
REVISION TO FOCUS IT ON
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
CLIMATE ACTION, BUT FOR NOW, WE
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE CEQA IS
BEING ABUSED AND WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION. I AGREE WITH THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD, I
THINK YOU HAD YOUR MIC UP. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I THINK I'D LIKE
TO GIVE A CLEAR EXPLANATION
ABOUT THE HIGHER EDUCATION
HOUSING, BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WAS SORT OF CHAPTER AND VERSE OF
WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET. BUT
BASICALLY, WE AS A LEGISLATURE
DID $3 BILLION FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION, HOUSING. WE DID IT AT
THE TIME THAT THERE WAS THE
BUDGET WAS MUCH MORE FLUSH. IT
WAS PROPOSED THAT WE CUT OUT
ABOUT HALF OF THAT AND NOT DO IT
AT ALL, BECAUSE THE BUDGET
TANKED AND THE COMPROMISE WAS,
IS THAT THERE WOULD BE LEASE
REVENUE BONDS AND THE PEOPLE
THAT RECEIVED THE GRANTS ARE NOT
THE ONES THAT PAY THEM. SO IN
ESSENCE, THIS IS NOT A COST.
THAT'S GOING TO BE PASSED ALONG.
BUT THIS KEEPS US FROM PULLING
BACK 13 GRANTS AND THE ONE THING
THAT WAS DELAYED IN ALL THIS WAS
THE ACTUAL MECHANISM FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THAT'S
WHAT'S HERE IN THE BUDGET. IS IT
FINALLY HAS THE MECHANISM TO
DEAL WITH THE WHAT THE GRANTS
ARE AND WHAT WE THE I THINK
WHATEVER THE NUMBER WAS $3
BILLION. ALL OF IT WAS OUT THE
DOOR IN GRANTS EXCEPT FOR A
COUPLE OF HUNDRED MILLION. THIS
BUDGET SWEEPS THE COUPLE OF
HUNDRED MILLION. AND THEN PUTS
THE MECHANISM IN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE 13 GRANTS ARE 15
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
HELD IN THE BUDGET AND ARE
ACTUALLY MADE. SO, THIS IS A
GOOD THING, AND IT HAS THE
GENERAL FUND PICK UP THE COST OF
THE OF THE LEASE REVENUE BONDS
SO THAT IT DOESN'T STOP THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FROM HAVING
THEIR, HOUSING PROJECTS PENCIL
OUT. SO IN ESSENCE, THIS IS A
GOOD THING TO PRESERVE FOR
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS THE
POSSIBILITY OF HOUSING IT AT
HIGHER EDUCATION. AND THEN LET
ME MAKE A COUPLE OF OTHER
COMMENTS, JUST IN GENERAL, ABOUT
THE EDUCATION BUDGET. I THINK
THE, THE, THE K THROUGH 14 HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED AT LENGTH AND IN
ESSENCE ISN'T CHANGING
SUBSTANTIALLY EXCEPT FOR SOME
EXTRA, TRANCHE OF REVENUES FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET. AND
GIVEN ALL THE OPTIONS FOR CUTS
AND BAD THINGS, IT IS A GOOD
OUTCOME. BUT FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION, THE OUTLINES THAT WE
HAD IN THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
ARE IN THIS BUDGET. AND INSTEAD
OF $125 MILLION CUT TO èC AND A
$75 MILLION CUT TO CSU, WHICH IS
WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISE, THIS REVERTS BACK TO THE
COMPACTS AND DOES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN THIS YEAR AND NEXT
YEAR, AND DEFERS THE CUTS TO THE
OUT YEAR. AND FRANKLY, IN THE
HOPE THAT THE BUDGET RECOVERS OR
WE HAVE A WAY THAT THOSE CUTS
WILL NOT BE REALIZED IN THE OUT
YEAR. SO THIS IS AFTER SOME
REALLY, DIFFICULT
RECOMMENDATIONS, A GREAT OUTCOME
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION. AND THEN
ALSO, WE WERE ABLE TO DO THE
NURSING SUPPORT HERE BECAUSE
JOBS ARE MENTIONED, THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OF NURSES AND A PROGRAM
TO REALLY TRY TO AUGMENT THE
NUMBER OF NURSES COMING OUT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IS HERE. AND
THE RESTORATION OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS TAX, SCHOLARSHIP IS HERE.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE, AS
I SAID IN OUR LAST HEARING, THIS
IS RIGHT AT THE TIME, PARENTS
AND STUDENTS ARE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT TO GO AND TRYING
TO PENCIL OUT THEIR BUDGETS. AND
SO A PIECE OF THIS THAT YOU WILL
NOTE IN THE BACKUP OF THE
TRAILER, BILL, IS TO POSTPONE
THE DEADLINE FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP UNTIL JULY
1ST. SO THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
THIS BUDGET CAN BE UNDERSTOOD BY
THE PARENTS AND THE SCHOOLS AND
THE STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THE BEST OUTCOME FOR THEM IN
TRYING TO MAKE THEIR EDUCATION
PENCIL OUT. AND PEOPLE NOT HAVE
TO GO INTO DEBT. SO JUST GIVEN
WHERE WE WERE ALONG THE WAY,
THIS IS A VERY GOOD BUDGET FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION AND WE NOW HAVE
OUR CHARGE FOR THE NEXT 12
MONTHS TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN REPEAT THIS AGAIN, BUT I
THIS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED SO MUCH
THAT I THINK SOME PEOPLE TAKE IT
FOR GRANTED, AND I WANT TO CALL
IT OUT JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR LAIRD, ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. YEAH, I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO, THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR SHARING THIS
THIS OVERVIEW AND FOR ALL OF THE
HARD WORK OF OUR COLLEAGUES ON
THIS BUDGET. I WANTED TO JUST
RAISE A MORE OF A QUESTION AND
COMMENT JUST ON THE MIDDLE MILE,
IF YOU COULD SAY, I KNOW WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS
AND FEELING, OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
HOW WE ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE
OUR PROGRESS IN GETTING ACCESS
TO SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. I WONDER IF YOU
COULD SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YOU KNOW, WHERE WHERE WE LANDED
ON, ENSURING, THAT WE MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS, BUT THAT WE ALSO,
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO WHERE THE
PUC IS GOING IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT, THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE NOW IDENTIFIED IN THE
MIDDLE MILE PRIORITIES ARE, IN
FACT, SEE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILD OUT THAT, THAT WE WANT TO
SEE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES. I
THINK, WE'VE DONE ALL THAT WE,
WE COULD DO GIVEN WHERE WE
STARTED IN THIS BUDGET. AND THAT
WAS ONE OF THE AREAS WHERE WE
HAD TO HAVE SOME PRETTY INTENSE
NEGOTIATIONS. BUT JUST TO
CLARIFY WHERE WE LANDED AND, YOU
KNOW, HOW ARE WE GOING TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROCESS MOVES FORWARD?
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I
WILL TURN OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
FOR THE DETAILS ON THAT. GOOD
MORNING, MEMBERS. DANIELLE
BRENDA WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO THE BUDGET, AB 108,
AS WELL AS AB 164, BOTH INCLUDE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
POINT TO, CONNECTING THE MIDDLE
MILE TO AND THE MIDDLE MILE
MILES TO THOSE FFA GRANTS, AS
WELL AS SOME OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES. AND CAN YOU SAY MORE
ABOUT HOW, OUR WE ARE MONITORING
THAT PROCESS, REPORTING IN TERMS
OF TIMELINE ON THAT, IF YOU CAN
SPECIFY A LITTLE MORE DETAIL ON
THE REPORTING ON THAT SO THAT
YOU KNOW, WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE PUC IS
MAKING PROGRESS ON THIS AND
WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS IN A WAY
THAT WE DON'T RUN INTO ANOTHER
BUDGET CRISIS AND THEN STILL NOT
HAVE THOSE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES PRIORITIZED. SO JUST
WANT TO, IF YOU COULD SHARE WHAT
WHAT THAT REPORTING LOOKS LIKE,
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL, I CAN
GIVE SOME DETAILS, A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THAT, SO CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THAT THE PUC YOU
MENTIONED, MAKING SURE THAT
THERE WAS SOME OVERSIGHT THERE,
TO WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH A
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR, TO
PROVIDE K¾T LOCATIONS FOR THE
STATEWIDE OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE
MILE BROADBAND NETWORK. AND I
THINK THAT CONSULTATION IS GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT, THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THAT K¾T WORK WITH THE
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER, AND AS
THEY'RE AS THEY'RE DEVELOPING
THE MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND
NETWORK TO WORK WITH LAST MILE
GRANT, PROJECTS, AWARDEES TO
ENSURE THAT THE SEGMENT SUPPORT
THAT LAST MILE CONNECTION. ALSO
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A MIDDLE MILE
TO HAVE TO HAVE A LAST MILE AND
CONNECTIONS THERE. IT REQUIRES
K¾T IN THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR TO MINIMIZE
DISRUPTION DUE TO EXCAVATION,
AND THEN LASTLY REQUIRES THE
CPUC TO PROVIDE K¾T AND THE
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR WITH
INFORMATION AGAIN ON THAT LAST
MILE GRANT. GRANT AWARDS. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAD SOME GUARDRAILS
IN THERE AROUND HOW WE'RE GOING
TO REPORT AND TRACK THAT. AND,
VERY EXCITED TO SEE THE
INVESTMENT IN HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS AS WELL, VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR EFFORTS TO
BUILD A REPRESENTATIVE AND FAIR,
WORKFORCE AND TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE GETTING ACCESS
TO THOSE HIGH ROAD CAREERS. SO,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND FOR THE REPORT. OKAY. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
YES. SENATOR MENGIBAR, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, I, YOU KNOW, FOR
I'M PRETTY I'M PRETTY HAPPY. AND
FOR THE MOST PART WITH THIS
BUDGET AND I'M REALLY THRILLED
THAT THE THREE PARTIES CAME
TOGETHER. AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WE WERE ABLE TO RESTORE A LOT,
YOU KNOW, THROUGH THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE CHAIR AND, LEADERS OF
BOTH HOUSES, BECAUSE IT WAS A
DIFFICULT YEAR THIS YEAR TO GET
ALL THESE PROPOSALS FOR CUTS AND
SO FORTH, AND HAVING PEOPLE COME
UP AND, CRY AND BEG THAT WE
WOULDN'T CUT IT. AND THIS BODY
STOOD VERY STRONG, AND WE GOT TO
A PLACE WHERE I THINK, FOR THE
MOST PART, VERY COMFORTABLE
GIVING THE $48 BILLION DEFICIT.
SO I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE
OUTCOME. AND ON MCO, I THINK,
THE MONEY IS GOING TO BE USED TO
OFFSET THE LOW REIMBURSEMENT
RATES PLUS MORE. I MEAN, YOU ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE COLLEAGUES TO
GO TO YOUR DISTRICT AND SAY OUR
SENIOR ADULT DAY CARES ARE GOING
TO GET PAID MORE, REIMBURSE
MORE, BE OPEN LONGER, BE ABLE TO
HIRE MORE PEOPLE. OUR PEDIATRIC
DAY CARE CENTERS ARE GOING TO BE
REIMBURSED MORE PEOPLE WHO LIVE,
WHO ARE NON-AMBULATORY, WHO LIVE
IN HOMES ARE GOING TO GET PAID
MORE CONGREGATE HEALTH LIVING,
PRIVATE DUTY NURSES ARE GOING TO
GET PAID MORE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS ARE GETTING ALMOST THE
SAME FOR MEDICARE RATES. THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES TO CLOSE THAT GAP FOR
EQUITY, WE GOT HUGE WINS WITH
THE MCO TAX AND REALLY ENSURING
THAT WE UTILIZE THAT FOR AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. AND ONE OF THE
GREATEST THINGS THAT I'M ONE OF
THE THINGS I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT ALSO IS THE SPECIALIZED
DENTAL GRANT CAPACITIES. IF YOU
DIDN'T KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO
HAVE, DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES, IT'S VERY RARE TO
FIND A DENTAL, TO FIND A
DENTIST, TO DO WORK BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO BE PLACED UNDER, AND WE
HAVE, I THINK ABOUT MY NIECES
AND NEPHEW WHO NEED TO GO TO THE
DENTIST, AND THEY CAN'T GO
BECAUSE THERE'S NO PEOPLE
AVAILABLE FOR THEM. AND THOSE
GRANTS WERE GOING TO BE PAUSED,
AND WE WERE ABLE TO CLAW THAT
BACK, WHICH IS REALLY AMAZING.
BUT THERE'S THREE THEMES THAT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHERE WE
COULD HAVE DONE MORE. AND I KNOW
THIS DEFICIT, YOU CAN'T GET ALL
THE WINS. BUT THREE PROMISES WE
MADE, WE MADE PROMISES TO THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY ON RATE REFORM, AND
WE'RE PUSHING IT OUT SIX MONTHS.
WE MADE PROMISE TO THE CHILD
CARE, COMMUNITY THAT WE WERE
GOING TO HIT 200,000 SLOTS IN
EVERY SINGLE YEAR. WE WERE GOING
TO ADD. BUT WE HAVE A PAUSE
RIGHT NOW. AND WE MADE A FORGOT
THE THIRD ONE. WE MADE A PROMISE
TO THE FOSTER CARE COMMUNITY
THAT WE WERE GOING TO HAVE
FOSTER RATE REFORMS BY NEXT YEAR
OR 2026, BUT THAT WAS PUSHED OUT
ANOTHER YEAR. THREE BIG PROMISES
TO THREE REALLY BIG MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. WHILE I KNOW WE HAD
TO NEGOTIATE AND FIND A COMMON
GROUND, THAT'S WE HAVE TO
COMPROMISE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE,
THOSE ARE SOMEWHAT LOSSES TO
THESE COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN,
TACKING DOWN HOW MANY DAYS LEFT
THERE UNTIL THEY WERE GOING TO
GET A RATE REFORM. MY HOPE, AND
I KNOW THAT WE'LL CONTINUE TO
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO IF THERE'S A
WAY TO START IT SOONER. THERE'S
A WAY TO UNPAUSE THE CHILD CARE
SLOTS, THESE ARE THESE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE REALLY
BENEFICIAL FOR OUR COMMUNITY TO
BE SUCCESSFUL AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. BUT OUTSIDE OF THAT, I
STILL THINK, AT LEAST WE DIDN'T
PAUSE THEM INDEFINITELY. AND I
KNOW WE HAD TO FIND A COMMON
GROUND ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES
TO PROTECT OTHER PROGRAMS AS
WELL. BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHILE THIS COULD BE A
WIN FOR US, IT COULD BE
DETRIMENTAL TO SOME COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO THEY NEED THAT RATE
REFORM RIGHT NOW, FOSTER FOSTER
CARE, COMMUNITIES WHO CAN'T WAIT
ANOTHER YEAR. BUT I DO WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
WORKING WITH US ON COMING TO A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN AT LEAST BE
IT CAN BE DIGESTIBLE FOR US. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
YES MR. VICE CHAIR, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, A
QUESTION, WITH REGARD TO
PROPOSITION 98, THE MANEUVER
RELATIVE TO THE OVER FUNDING OF
THE 2223 YEAR. UNDERSTAND HOW
AND WHY THAT HAPPENED, BUT ARE
WE CONTINUING TO HANDLE THAT AS
WAS PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET? OR HAVE WE SEEN
THE WISDOM OF THE, I THINK,
BETTER PROPOSAL OF THE LEAD
ANALYST FOR THAT PARTICULAR
OVERPAYMENT? I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE WHAT THE LEAD ANALYST
PROPOSED, BUT, THE AGREEMENT
DOES INCLUDE, THE STRUCTURE THAT
WAS PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. BUT I WILL DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FOR PARTICULARS. YEAH.
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO IT'S A
MODIFIED VERSION OF WHAT WAS
PROPOSED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND MADE REVISION, THE
MANEUVER WOULD HAVE BEEN AROUND
8.8 BILLION UNDER THOSE
PROPOSALS. THE FINAL AGREEMENT
REFLECTS ROUGHLY 6.2 BILLION OF,
PRIOR YEAR RESOURCES FOR STATE
PURPOSES ONLY AT THE STATE LEVEL
BEING ACCRUED AND ACCOUNTED FOR
IN FUTURE YEARS. SO ESSENTIALLY,
IT'S A DIFFERENT NUMBER, BUT
CONCEPTUALLY SAME APPROACH,
CONCEPTUALLY THE SAME APPROACH
FOR THAT PRIOR YEAR. THE ONE
CORE DIFFERENCE IS THAT THE
AMOUNT IS INCLUDED. THAT 6.2
BILLION IS INCLUDED WHEN
COMPUTING THE GUARANTEE IN 2324,
WHICH IS PART OF THE REASON THAT
THE OVERALL PACKAGE PROPOSES A
SUSPENSION IN THE CREATION OF
MAINTENANCE FACTOR. NOW THE LAO
CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M INACCURATE
IN ANY WAY, BUT IT JUST SEEMED
THAT WAS SUCH A MORE SIMPLE
APPROACH TO, RECOGNIZE THE
OVERPAYMENT. BUT REIMBURSE IT
THROUGH AVAILABLE PROPOSITION 98
RESERVES AND WE'RE DONE WITH IT,
AS OPPOSED TO PUSHING IT INTO
FUTURE YEARS, IS THERE ANY
CORRECTION THAT OR, ADDITIONS
THAT YOU WOULD ADD TO MY PERHAPS
INADEQUATE ARTICULATION WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE? I
THINK I AGAIN, OUR
RECOMMENDATION HAD BEEN TO USE
THE PROPOSITION AND RESERVE TO
ADDRESS THE ENTIRE SHORTFALL IN
22, 23, THE FINAL PACKAGE USES
THE PROP 98 RESERVE FOR A
VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS IN
PARTICULAR, IT'S TO COVER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA, THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDING
FORMULA. IN IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET YEAR. DOES IT THAT'S THE
CURRENT BUDGET PROPOSAL. YEAH.
THE WHAT'S THE BUDGET BEFORE YOU
HERE. YES. AND DOES THAT WHAT
DOES THAT LEAVE IN THE PROP 98
RESERVE FUND OVERALL. OVERALL
THE PACKAGE INCLUDES $1.1
BILLION REMAINING IN THE PROP 98
RESERVE. SO THE ESSENTIALLY ALL
OF IT WAS WITHDRAWN AS PART OF,
AS PART OF COVERING COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROGRAMS. BUT
THEN AS A RESULT, COMPARED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION, THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION WOULD
HAVE EXHAUSTED ALL OF THE
RESERVE AMOUNT, THIS THIS
PACKAGE, WHICH INCLUDES THE
REVENUE INCREASES THAT WERE IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE, RESULTS
IN ADDITIONAL PROP EIGHT
SPENDING AND 1.1 BILLION OF THAT
IS SET ASIDE INTO THE RESERVE.
SO THAT'S AVAILABLE MOVING
FORWARD. AND, SENATOR, CAN I
JUST, CLARIFY THAT I BELIEVE
THAT THE LOUSE PROPOSAL WOULD
HAVE LED TO CUTS IN EDUCATION
AND THE PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE
IN FRONT OF YOU, WHICH WAS, A
MODIFICATION OF THE PROPOSAL THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED WOULD
NOT WOULD HAVE MITIGATED THOSE
CUTS TO EDUCATION. SO JUST THAT
WAS AN IMPORTANT FACTOR FOR US
IN PUTTING FORWARD THIS
PROPOSAL. WILL THAT PRESUMES
THAT THE ONLY CHOICE OF, CUTS
AND REIMBURSEMENTS IS IN THAT
ONE AREA. THE BUDGET TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT A WIDE ARRAY OF
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
EXPENDITURES. SO THE ALTERNATIVE
CHOICES ARE NOT QUITE THAT
NARROW. BUT RATHER THAN DIVE
DEEP INTO THAT PHILOSOPHIC
APPROACH TO BUDGETING, I'LL JUST
MOVE ON. IT IS AMAZING TO ME,
AND I KNOW THIS HAS BEEN DONE
BEFORE, AND WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY ALSO, BUT HOW WE CAN
ARTICULATE WITH A STRAIGHT FACE
TRANSFERRING PAYROLL FROM JUNE
TO JULY IN ORDER TO SAVE MONEY.
IS FASCINATING TO ME. ALL THAT
REALLY MEANS IS, BY THE WAY,
RATHER THAN 12 PAY PERIODS IN,
THE BUDGET YEAR, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE 13 PAY PERIODS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR, AUTOMATICALLY
INCREASING THE PROBLEM IN THE
BUDGET YEAR UNLESS WE DO THE
SAME THING AGAIN A YEAR FROM
NOW, WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY NOT
IMPOSSIBLE. WITH REGARD TO THE
CAPITAL ANNEX AND THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT SCHOOL REFORM, IT SOUNDS
TO ME LIKE WE MIGHT HAVE A
BIPARTISAN POTENTIAL BIPARTISAN
RESULT TO A LARGER, ADDRESSING
OF THE ABUSES OF SEQUA. AND WE
CAN CARRY THAT DISCUSSION ON, AT
ANOTHER TIME. THAT'S I IT MAKES
ME SOMEWHAT OPTIMISTIC, QUESTION
ABOUT, THE GOVERNOR'S, THE OPR
DEPARTMENT, LET'S TALK ABOUT
WHERE WE'VE BEEN AND WHERE WE'RE
GOING. SO CAN YOU TALK ABOUT,
HOW BIG OPR WAS IN 2018?
PERSONNEL AND DOLLARS, WHAT IT
IS NOW IN TERMS OF PERSONNEL AND
DOLLARS? AND HOW MUCH OF THAT IS
BEING TRANSFERRED TO THE,
CLEVERLY LABELED. GO SERVE? I
GUESS IT IS. GO CALI IS WHAT OPR
HAS BEEN. NOT ENTIRELY SURE WHY
THE NAME CHANGES, BUT
NONETHELESS, CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH, WHERE WE'VE BEEN, WHERE
WE ARE, AND MAYBE, EVEN IF YOU
DARE, WHERE WE'RE GOING? MARK
MENDEZ, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
SO I DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFIC
NUMBERS FOR 2018. AND 19, AND
THE, THE, THE CURRENT, OR THE
FISCAL YEAR 2324. NUMBERS. AND I
CAN CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP WITH
YOUR STAFF WITH, WITH THOSE
SPECIFIC DETAILS, SINCE I DON'T
HAVE IT IN FRONT OF ME. BUT I
REALLY WANT THIS PUBLICLY. YEAH
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
TO KNOW THAT NOT JUST ME. RIGHT.
BECAUSE I HAVE THE NUMBERS IN MY
OFFICE AND THE INCREASE HAS BEEN
LIKE 400% OR SOMETHING,
FANTASTICAL, LIKE THAT, WHERE
THERE HAD BEEN VIRTUALLY NO
INCREASE IN MANY YEARS PRIOR TO
THAT. SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THIS HUGE GROWTH
AND INCREASE IN SPENDING IS AND
THE IMPACT IT HAS ON THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. AND I WOULD NOTE THAT,
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE BIGGEST
FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTED TO THE
GROWTH WITHIN OPR ARE THE SURGE
OF FUNDING FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS, GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUNDS. AND SO A PORTION OF THOSE
FUNDS GOES TO OPR TO, IMPLEMENT,
CLIMATE MITIGATION RELATED
PROGRAMS. AND SO LARGELY, MUCH
OF THE GROWTH IS RELATED TO
THOSE FUNDS, THERE WERE ONE
TIME, GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATIONS
AND ALSO, FEDERAL FUNDS THROUGH
THE, THROUGH ERA ONE TIME FUNDS
THAT WILL ESSENTIALLY REDUCE,
DOWN, I THINK, BY 2025 OR THIS
NEXT FISCAL YEAR. AND SO, BUT
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS WERE
PRIMARILY CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
RELATED. WERE WERE, WERE, I
GUESS AUGMENTED WITH GENERAL
FUND OR SO THAT IT CAN CONTINUE.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE ESTABLISHED
GO SERVE OR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF SERVICE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT, WHICH WILL FOCUS ON
THOSE ASPECTS OF, OF, OF OPR
EXISTING OPERATIONS SO THAT, OPR
NOW THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
LAND USE AND CLIMATE INNOVATION
WILL FOCUS PRIMARILY ON, LAND
USE AND CLIMATE INNOVATION
RELATED WORK. AND SO WE'RE NOT
ADDING ANY NEW, ANY NEW ADMIN
STAFF WITHIN GO SERVE, GO SERVE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE SUPPORTED BY
OPR EXISTING ADMINISTRATIVE
OPERATIONS, TO AVOID HAVING TO
KIND OF ADD THAT, YOU KNOW, ADD
THAT ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERHEAD. SO, WE'RE THEY'LL BE
SHARING THOSE RESOURCES, I THINK
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF, OF
POSITIONS SHIFTING OVER TO, TO
GO SERVE, I, I THINK IT'S
CERTAINLY OVER 100 POSITIONS
THAT WILL BE MOVING OVER TO GO
SERVE, BUT I'LL HAVE TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU ON MORE SPECIFICS ON
THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS MOVING
OVER TO GO SERVE. I HAVE THAT
NUMBER THAT'S ABOUT 137 GOING TO
GO SERVE. AND I THINK IN IN
2018, THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS IN
OPR WAS SOMEWHERE AROUND 50.
SOME IT CERTAINLY, A FRACTION OF
WHAT IT WAS TODAY. AND THOSE
OTHER, THE OTHER SPENDING THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, THAT I
GUESS YOU'RE SAYING IS ACCOUNTED
FOR. THE BULK OF THE GROSS.
WHAT'S THE SOURCE OF THOSE
FUNDS? THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND, AND IT'S, I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE REVENUE
MECHANISM, BUT IT'S, IT'S A,
IT'S CERTAINLY THROUGH THROUGH
THAT FUND. IT'S NOT GENERAL
FUND, NOT GENERAL. NOT GENERAL
FUND, THAT IT MUST BE COMING
FROM BONDS OR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OR THE GRF IS THE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS, CAP AND TRADE FUND AND
WE'RE, TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT WE
DO WITH CAP AND TRADE IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS. RIGHT SO THIS
FUNDING COULD COULD CONTINUE ON
WITHOUT CAP AND TRADE. THEN IT
BECOMES GENERAL FUND. MY POINT
IS THIS HAS A HUGE IMPACT
DIRECTLY ON THE BUDGET,
POTENTIALLY ON THE BUDGET IN THE
FUTURE. THE GROWTH IN OPR HAS
BEEN ABSOLUTELY STUNNING, AND
WE'VE HAD SOME DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THAT. AND, SUBCOMMITTEE FOR BUT
I HOPE WE CONTINUE TO BECAUSE
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES IN
GOVERNMENT IS THE ALLOWANCE OF
GROWTH IN SPENDING AND NOT
REDUCTION IN SPENDING OUTSIDE OF
AND TRYING TO HANDLE A BUDGET
DISASTER. THAT DISCIPLINE IS NOT
TYPICALLY THERE. THAT'S NOT A
CRITICISM. IT'S JUST A REALITY.
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE KEEP A SPOTLIGHT,
BECAUSE I JUST HAVEN'T SEEN THE
GROWTH OF A OF A BUREAUCRACY TO
THE EXTENT THAT OPR HAS BEEN IN
THE LAST SIX YEARS OR SO, I JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT. AND,
SENATOR NEIL, I JUST WANT TO
MAKE A POINT THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS CONCERNED WITH
EFFICIENCIES. AND I THINK WE
ARE, THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF A
DEPARTMENT WHERE WE ARE TRYING
TO STREAMLINE AND TO BETTER,
CREATE A, A DEPARTMENT THAT HAS
AT ITS CORE FUNCTION THE MISSION
FOR WHAT IT WAS PROPOSED AND SO
THAT IS JUST THAT IS AN EXAMPLE
OF SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. AND OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A LOT OF EFFICIENCIES IN
PROPOSED IN THIS AGREEMENT,
ACROSS THE BOARD TO ADDRESS THE
BUDGET PROBLEM, BUT IN GENERAL,
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
INTERESTED IN AND WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE, WE
INTRODUCED SOME TRAILER BILL
THAT DEALT WITH THIS, THAT WE
WILL BE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
LEGISLATURE ON OVER THE SUMMER.
I WOULD LOVE TO HELP OUT WITH
THAT. I HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
EXPERIENCE WITH REGARD TO
PRIVATE SECTOR BUDGETS, WITH
REGARD TO COUNTY BUDGETS, WITH
REGARD TO STATE BUDGETS, NOT TO
TOOT MY HORN, BUT I'D LOVE TO
HELP OUT WITH THAT. IT'S JUST
THAT I AM EXCLUDED. BUT I OFFER
MY SERVICES FOR WHATEVER THAT'S
WORTH. THANK YOU. THE OKAY, MR.
VICE CHAIR, I NEED TO PRESENT A
FEW BILLS, SO I'M GOING TO HAND
THE GAVEL OVER TO YOU. BRAVE
MAN. AND AFTER WE AND AFTER
AFTER THE DISCUSSION AND
QUESTIONS. WILL, WILL BE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND THEN AFTER PUBLIC
COMMENT, WE WILL VOTE ON THE
BILLS. RIGHT. THANK YOU. WE'LL
PROBABLY BE DONE BEFORE YOU GET
BACK. THE LAST POINT THAT I WANT
TO MAKE IS WITH REGARD TO THE
TAXATION ISSUES, I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT, THE ESPECIALLY
THE NET OPERATING LOSS, ASPECT
OF THAT, IS BEING, POTENTIALLY
NOT DEFERRED AS LONG AS IT WAS.
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA, BUT
IT'S A BAD IDEA TO ELIMINATE
THOSE ALLOWANCES IN THE FIRST
PLACE. THIS ISN'T A QUESTION.
UNLESS YOU WANT TO ADD SOMETHING
TO WHAT I SAY. I THINK
ELIMINATING THE NOL AS WE'VE,
BUSINESS HAS BECOME NOT ABLE TO
DEPEND UPON THAT, THAT, THAT TAX
ASPECT. SO MAYBE WE OUGHT TO
JUST REPEAL IT, WHICH WOULD BE A
HUGE MISTAKE, BECAUSE AS I'VE
SAID, WHEN BUSINESSES LOSE
MONEY, THEIR CAPITAL IS BEING
DEPLETED. WHEN THEY START MAKING
MONEY AND BEGINNING TO REPLENISH
THEIR CAPITAL TO IMMEDIATELY
BEGIN REQUIRING THEM TO PAY
TAXES TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
TO REPLENISH THAT CAPITAL IS
JUST SIMPLY UNFAIR AND CERTAINLY
NOT GOOD FOR OVERALL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SO TO DO ANYTHING
WITH THAT FEATURE, I THINK, IS
UNWISE. BUT ESPECIALLY TO GIVE
IT AND TAKE IT BACK AND GIVE IT
AND TAKE IT BACK AS WE
CONTINUALLY DO. BUSINESS NEEDS
CERTAINTY. THEY NEED TO KNOW
WHAT THEY CAN DEPEND UPON, AND
THEY CAN'T DEPEND UPON THIS. AND
IT'S I THINK IT'S AN EQUITY
FACTOR. THE OTHER CREDIT, THE
SAME THING. SO WE SHOULDN'T BE
DOING THAT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SO AND ONE THING I WANTED TO ADD
TO, SENATOR MENGER'S COMMENTS IS
, THE AREAS OF THE BUDGET THAT
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT ARE THE
AREAS OF THE BUDGET THAT AFFECT
ARGUABLY THE MOST MARGINAL OF
OUR CITIZENS, ARGUABLY THE MOST.
AND SHE HIGHLIGHTED, NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS BUDGET. SO
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS. AND
QUESTIONS, ANY OTHERS? I DIDN'T
SEE ANYBODY ELSE PRIOR TO ME
RAISING MY HAND. SENATOR BECKER,
I THANK YOU ALL OF A COUPLE OF
QUICK COMMENTS. AND, MAYBE IT'S
A LITTLE BIT MORE ON THE ON THE,
ON THE FLOOR TODAY, BUT JUST AS
BUDGET SUB TWO CHAIR JUST WANT
TO, THANK THE STAFF. THANK THE
WHOLE BUDGET TEAM AND MY SUB
STAFF AND JUST A COUPLE, YOU
KNOW, QUICK, QUICK NOTES THAT,
THIS YEAR, FOR THE FIRST TIME,
CALIFORNIA IS POWERED BY CLEAN
ENERGY RESOURCES FOR 32 DAYS
STRAIGHT. AND THIS BUDGET
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH THE LAST
FOUR YEARS TO INCREASE CLEAN
ENERGY PROCUREMENT, INCREASE
GRID RELIABILITY, AND SHRINK THE
PROBABILITY OF BLACKOUTS, WE'VE
INCREASED BATTERY STORAGE
TENFOLD TO ABOUT 10,000MW.
DOUBLED THE SIZE, DOUBLED THE
SALE OF NEW ZERO EMISSION MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES. AND WE
EXCEEDED 100,000 PUBLIC CHARGERS
. IN ADDITION TO THAT, WE'VE
CONSERVED OR RESTORED NEARLY A
MILLION ACRES OF NATURAL LAND
AND INCREASED URBAN TREE CANOPY
BY OVER 200,000 TREES. THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO MANY PROGRAMS THAT
WE SAVED THROUGH THE WORK OF
THIS COMMITTEE AROUND, SMALL
FARMS. AROUND PROTECTION OF
INVASIVE FRUIT FLIES AND OTHER
CLIMATE EMERGENCIES, AND
ALLOWING 500,000 CALIFORNIANS TO
USE THEIR CALFRESH AT FARMERS
MARKETS BECAUSE WE SAVED THAT
PROGRAM AS WELL, IN ADDITION,
THE WILDFIRE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE, I THINK IS REALLY QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY BECAUSE IT ADDS TO
A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THAT WE'VE
PUT FORWARD AND THAT WE'VE NOW
BUILT THE LARGEST AERIAL
FIREFIGHTING FORCE IN THE WORLD,
69 AIRCRAFT, STRATEGICALLY
LOCATED AROUND 25 BASES, ABLE TO
RESPOND TO ANY WILDFIRE WITHIN
20 MINUTES. THAT'S BECAUSE OF
THE WORK THAT WE PUT FORWARD AND
WE'RE CONTINUING IN THIS BUDGET.
WE MADE THE HISTORIC INVESTMENTS
IN CAL FIRE TO REDUCE THE
WORKWEEK, AND WE FUNDED NOVEL,
BOTH FIRE SUPPRESSION
TECHNOLOGIES AS AND IN THIS
BUDGET, A LIDAR MAPPING, WHICH
IS GOING TO GREATLY HELP OUR,
OUR FIREFIGHTERS IN THE FUTURE.
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
AND NOTE SOME OF THE INVESTMENTS
WE'VE MADE THERE. AND I WAS JUST
TALKING TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES, AND I
AGREE WITH HER ON THE ON THE
SLOTS, WHICH ALSO JUST TALKING
ABOUT HOW, THE REAL IMPACT IN MY
DISTRICT OF SOME OF THE WORK
WE'VE DONE ON PAY THE LAST FEW
YEARS. SO WHEN I STARTED CHILD
CARE WORKERS IN MY DISTRICT, THE
STARTING SALARY WAS $17.50 AN
HOUR, AND THE MOST EXPENSIVE,
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE PARTS OF THE OF THE
STATE, BECAUSE THE WORK WE DID
MY VERY FIRST YEAR, BY 2022,
THAT WAS UP TO $23 AN HOUR, UP
27. STILL DIFFICULT FOR THE
AREA, BUT AN IMPROVEMENT. AND
NOW IT'S UP TO $28 AN HOUR. AND
THAT'S WITH MUCH IMPROVED HEALTH
BENEFITS, A RETIREMENT PLAN FOR
THE FIRST YEAR. THIS IS FOLKS IN
WORKING IN, IN STATE SUBSIDIZED
CHILD CARE AND, AND I DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT BECAUSE THAT WAS AN
EXAMPLE OF SOME OF THE, THE,
THE, THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
HERE THAT, HAS HAD AN IMPACT IN,
IN MY DISTRICT. SO I JUST WANT
TO NOTE THOSE AREAS IN SUB TWO
AND, AND, AND ONE AREA THERE,
AROUND THE, THE, THE, THE
WORKFORCE, AND HOW IT'S PLAYING
OUT, YOU KNOW, IN ON THIS, YOU
KNOW, IN OUR DISTRICTS AND, I
JUST WANT TO AGAIN THANK THE
BUDGET TEAM FOR ALL ITS WORK ON
THIS BUDGET TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU. ONE, I JUST
WANT TO AGAIN, THANK YOU ALL AS
WELL AS YOUR STAFF THAT'S NOT
SITTING AT THIS TABLE FOR
WORKING WITH ALL OF US, AND
COMING TO A DEAL. I THINK THAT
MOST OF US ARE RELATIVELY HAPPY
WITH THE BUDGET, I THINK THAT
WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT CUTS IN
AREAS THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN VERY BLOATED, I WILL SAY
THAT DEFINITELY IN BUDGET SUB
FIVE, I AM CONCERNED A LITTLE
BIT, YOU KNOW, WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CERTAIN
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE NO ACCESS
TO INCREASE OR GENERATE ANY MORE
REVENUE, SPECIFICALLY OUR
COURTS. IF YOU IF YOU REALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT IT, THEY'RE KIND
OF STUCK. I THINK WE DID SAVE A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF FUNDING
FOR THEM AS WELL AS YOU KNOW,
REALLY FOCUSED ON SOME OF THE
OVERSPENDING AND BLOAT IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS. I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, I THINK THAT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AND I THINK MANY
OTHER PEOPLE, WE DO HAVE A
BUDGET IN SO MANY OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE BLOATED AND
HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN BLOATED.
I HAVE ASKED SPECIFICALLY FOR
CERTAIN PROGRAMS, YOU KNOW, LINE
ITEMS AND WHERE DOES THE FUNDING
GO TO AND SO FORTH. AND I WAS
TOLD SPECIFICALLY THAT WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO REALLY 100%
TRACK IT. AND LIKE, I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT AND, YOU KNOW, WE KEEP
THROWING MONEY AT DIFFERENT
PROBLEMS AND YET NOT SEEING
NECESSARILY THE BEST RETURN.
RIGHT AND EVEN IF FUNDING WAS,
SECURED 20 PLUS YEARS AGO, YOU
KNOW, IS THAT PROGRAM VIABLE? IS
THAT PROGRAM EVEN SUCCESSFUL?
WHAT IS THE EFFICACY OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND THE ORIGINAL
INTENTION VERSUS THE INTENTION?
IT SHOULD SERVE TODAY AS THINGS
EVOLVE, AND I DON'T THINK THAT
WE DO ENOUGH ANALYSIS OF THAT
ACROSS DEPARTMENTS. SO, YOU
KNOW, I CHAIR BUDGET SUB FIVE.
THAT'S ONE PIECE OF WHAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT, HAVING, YOU KNOW
WHAT 12 CONTRACTORS, 700
SUBCONTRACTORS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, IS THAT REALLY
VIABLE? IS THAT NECESSARY? IS
THAT NEEDED? YOU KNOW, HOW MUCH
MONEY ARE WE SPENDING PER
CONTRACTOR? RIGHT. PER
SUBCONTRACTOR? WHAT IS THEIR
SUCCESS METRICS? WHAT IS THEIR
GOALS? YOU KNOW, ARE THEY
MEETING THOSE GOALS. AND I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S TRACKED AT
ALL. YOU KNOW, IT'S HEY, THEY
SERVICE THIS MANY PEOPLE. AND
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH THE GIST OF
IT. RIGHT. BUT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REHABILITATION
AND, AND MUCH MORE, IT'S LIKE,
OKAY, ARE THESE INDIVIDUALS
REINTEGRATING INTO SOCIETY VERY
WELL. WHAT ARE THEIR CHALLENGES?
AND I'M GONNA BE HONEST, ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT I
CONSISTENTLY HEAR FROM THIS
POPULATION THAT REENTERS SOCIETY
IS HOUSING. RIGHT? AND I HAVEN'T
SEEN ANY MOVEMENT IN REGARDS TO
MAKING RENTING EASIER FOR THESE
FOLKS, WHICH SHOULD BE A METRIC
OF THESE PROGRAMS AS TO WHAT IS
A SUCCESSFUL REENTRY. RIGHT? ARE
THEY TRYING TO RENT A UNIT
THROUGH THEIR MOTHER AND
FATHER'S NAME? A BOYFRIEND OR
GIRLFRIEND'S NAME, A SIBLING'S
NAME THAT IS NOT SUCCESS, THAT
IS NOT STANDING ON YOUR OWN TWO
FEET, WHICH IS WHAT THESE PEOPLE
WANT AND NEED AND DESERVE, SO I
HIGHLIGHT THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
ONE DEPARTMENT AND ONE GROUP AND
ONE EFFORT AND ONE CORE FOCUS OF
A DEMOGRAPHIC. BUT I CAN EXPAND
THAT SAME THOUGHT PROCESS WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HEALTH.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO SAY IT, BUT
IT IS VERY, VERY BLOATED IN
REGARDS TO THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE ARE SPENDING. AND YET IF
YOU TALK TO THE AVERAGE PERSON,
A PERSON ON MEDI-CAL, THEY STILL
DO NOT RECEIVE ADEQUATE CARE
ACROSS THE BOARD, RIGHT? WE CAN
TALK ABOUT HOW TO EVEN BE ON
MEDI-CAL. YOU HAVE TO BE AT 128%
OF THE POVERTY LEVEL, RIGHT? WE
HAVE A GROWING SENIOR POPULATION
THAT IS NOT AT THEIR PRIME.
EARNING YEARS WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO AFFORD SOME OF THE CARE THAT
THEY NEED AND DESERVE. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NURSING HOMES,
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES,
RETIREMENT CENTERS, MUCH MORE.
AND IT'S MY GENERATION THAT'S
IMPACTED OF TAKING CARE OF THEIR
AGING PARENTS, POTENTIALLY
STARTING THEIR OWN FAMILIES. THE
HOUSING CRISIS, THE STUDENT LOAN
CRISIS, YOU NAME IT. AND WE HAVE
THE MOST AMOUNT OF MONEY GOING
INTO HEALTH, BUT NOT NECESSARILY
THE BEST RETURN THAT WE SEE. AS
TO REAL CARE AND SOLVING THE
REAL ISSUES. RIGHT. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE A DEEPER DIVE AND,
YOU KNOW, I'VE HEARD FROM MY, MY
COLLEAGUES, SOME OF THEM, AS
WELL AS THE, THE LARGER PUBLIC,
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
BUDGET AND HOW IT'S NOT CLEAR
AND THE BUDGET IS BEEN AVAILABLE
SINCE JANUARY, WE KNOW THAT,
RIGHT. THE OVERALL YOU KNOW,
KIND OF BIG PICTURE, AND IT GOES
INTO A LOT OF DETAIL. AND I
THINK THAT WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IS IN THE COMING MONTHS IS
ALSO WHERE ARE THE POTENTIALS
FOR REMOVING DUPLICATIVE
SERVICES, STREAMLINING
EFFICIENCIES AND POTENTIALLY
TRYING TO SAVE MONEY THAT FROM
PROGRAMS THAT 20, 30 YEARS AGO
MADE SENSE. BUT TODAY DOESN'T,
BECAUSE IN THE LAST MEETING I
DID STATE TO YOU ALL THAT
GOVERNMENT AND GOVERNMENT, YOU
KNOW, WORKS TO SUPPORT THE
PEOPLE, BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THEY HAVE A MINDSET OF USE IT OR
LOSE IT, RATHER THAN ADMITTING
THAT THIS DOESN'T WORK ANYMORE.
AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE ANOTHER
CONCERN WHERE SOMETIMES WE DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT SHIFTING
POSITIONS AND MUCH MORE, BECAUSE
THE HONEST TRUTH AND THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM IS THAT,
YOU KNOW, THE MAJORITY OF OUR
BUDGET GOES TO, PERSONNEL COSTS,
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
PRIORITIZE. AGAIN, THE
PROGRAMING AND THE EFFORT FOR
THE AVERAGE PERSON OF WHO WE
SERVE. FIRST AND FOREMOST, AND
THE REASON WHY I BRING UP HEALTH
IS BECAUSE I'M GONNA BE HONEST.
I'M GONNA PITCH THIS MEDI-CAL.
WILL COVER A DENTAL IMPLANT
REMOVAL LIKE A DENTAL REMOVAL, A
TOOTH REMOVAL, BUT NOT AN
IMPLANT. AND, I THINK IT'S ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A GROWING SENIOR
POPULATION THAT CAN'T GET A
TOOTH IMPLANTED, BUT WILL GET 12
TEETH REMOVED. RIGHT? IS THAT
REALLY FAIR? IS THAT QUALITY OF
LIFE? ARE WE, SERVING THE
COMMUNITY IN THAT REGARD? SO I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANY MONEY ON THE TABLE TO
ACTUALLY PUSH THIS FORWARD. IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT,
AGAIN, WE ARE SEEING OUR
PROGRAMS AND DOES IT SERVE THE
POPULATION. AND THIS IS A
GROWING POPULATION THAT CANNOT
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES. SO I
SAY ALL OF THIS BECAUSE I THINK
THAT FOR ME, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
MORE EFFICIENCIES KIND OF PUT
FORWARD. RIGHT. WE HAVE A LOT OF
DEPARTMENTS WE HEARD FROM THE
LAST SPEAKER THAT THERE'S
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT GROWING TO
ONLY FOCUS ON THIS ONE CORE
ISSUE OR TWO CORE ISSUES, AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF PROGRAMS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT, THAT SEEM
DUPLICATIVE EVEN WHEN I SEE IT
RIGHT. AND IF WE CAN HAVE THAT
ON PAPER, THESE ARE ALL THE
PROGRAMS UNDER THIS UMBRELLA
THAT COVER X, Y, Z. AND IF THERE
ARE DUPLICATIVE SERVICES, THEY
NEED TO BE CONSOLIDATED. THEY
TRULY NEED TO BE CONSOLIDATED
BECAUSE ONE, IT'S NOT CLEAR.
TWO, DOES IT ACTUALLY SERVE THE
PUBLIC? AND THREE, WHAT ARE THE
GOALS? AND ARE WE ACHIEVING
THOSE GOALS? AND I HAVE NOT SEEN
ANY METRICS, ANY METRICS ON ANY
OF THE CONTRACTS THAT WE GIVE
OUT ON ANY OF THE PROGRAMING
THAT WE GIVE OUT. AND IF WE HAVE
A PROGRAM JUST TO HAVE A PROGRAM
AND SAY WE'RE DOING SOMETHING,
BUT IT'S A COMPLETE FAILURE,
THAT'S A CONCERN FOR ME. THAT'S
A CONCERN FOR THE PUBLIC. THAT'S
A CONCERN FOR ONE OF THE
WEALTHIEST STATES IN THE NATION.
RIGHT IN THE WORLD. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE SUCCESSES
VERSUS US THROWING MONEY AT A
PROBLEM. FOR EXAMPLE, WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING, AND WE THREW
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AT IT. BUT
WHY WASN'T IT AS SUCCESSFUL AS
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN? RIGHT AND
AGAIN, IT'S BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THESE METRICS. WE THINK
THAT THAT JUST THROWING MONEY AT
A PROBLEM IS GOING TO BE, YOU
KNOW, THE END ALL, BE ALL. BUT
WE SHOULD HOLD THE GROUPS AND
THE ORGANIZATIONS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR WHAT SUCCESS LOOKS LIKE.
PERMANENT HOUSING, WRAP AROUND
SERVICES. AND THEN AGAIN,
ANOTHER METRIC TO SAY A YEAR
FROM NOW. HOW SUCCESSFUL WAS
THIS PROGRAM? RIGHT. WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
, WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
DEVELOPMENT, DEVELOPMENT,
DEVELOPMENT AND WE'RE PUTTING
MONEY IN STREAMLINING EFFORTS
FOR ADUS AND MUCH MORE. ADUS ARE
NOT AFFORDABLE HALF OF THE TIME.
IT'S NOT EVEN FOR RENTERS. IT'S
FOR A MAN CAVE OR A SHED AS THEY
CALL IT, RIGHT? NO, SERIOUSLY.
AND THERE'S NO, DEED
RESTRICTIONS ON IT. THERE'S NO
NOTHING. RIGHT. SO AGAIN, WE'RE
THROWING MONEY AT A PROBLEM AND
NOT REALLY SOLVING THE PROBLEM.
SO I SAY ALL THAT JUST TO AGAIN,
REALLY HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT
WE NEED TO PUT SOME MORE METRICS
INTO IT. IT SHOULD BE FULLY
TRANSPARENT ONLINE AVAILABLE FOR
ANY AVERAGE RESIDENT IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
IT AND DIVE IN DEEP INTO THE
LINE ITEMS AND THE COST. CITIES
DO IT TO SOME EXTENT. I HAVE NOT
SEEN THE STATE GO AS DEEP AS WE
NEED TO. WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE A
BIGGER BUDGET AND IT'S HARDER,
BUT THIS SHOULD BE ONE OF THE
EFFORTS WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE DMV AND STREAMLINING THE
DMV. DMV ACROSS THE BOARD SHOULD
ALREADY HAVE THEIR ELECTRONIC
SYSTEM SET UP INTO PLACE, RATHER
THAN MAKING IT TAKE THREE YEARS.
IN ANY INDUSTRY, IMPLEMENTING A
NEW TECHNOLOGY SHOULD NOT TAKE
THREE YEARS. IT'S RIDICULOUS.
THESE ARE JOKES TO THE AVERAGE
PERSON, RIGHT? SO I SAY THAT AND
AGAIN I DO APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK YOU GUYS ARE DOING. I DON'T
NEED A RESPONSE, BUT I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE IS STILL A
LOT OF WORK TO DO. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NEILL. I DO HAVE A
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION. IN
TERMS OF THE POSITIONS AT OPR
INITIALLY. SO BACK IN 20 1819,
THE TOTAL POSITIONS, WERE 40
ABOUT 48. THE TOTAL BUDGET AT
THAT POINT WAS 625 MILLION, OF
WHICH 548 MILLION WAS THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
THE CAP AND TRADE FUND THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT, IN THE 2324 YEAR,
WHICH IS THE CURRENT YEAR, TOTAL
POSITIONS ARE ABOUT 149 AND THE
BUDGET IS 1.1 BILLION, OF WHICH
712 MILLION IS GENERAL. SORRY
GRF. SO AGAIN, CAP AND TRADE, SO
JUST GETTING THE DETAILS FOR
YOU. I KNOW YOU WANTED TO HAVE
THAT. YEAH. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT AND IT'S GOOD TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT AS WE MOVE ON,
DEPENDING UPON WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE CAP AND TRADE SYSTEM, IF YOU
WILL. BUT THAT TRULY IS STUNNING
GROWTH. THANKS FOR THE
STATISTIC. AND MAY I ALSO
CORRECT SOMETHING FOR THE
RECORD, EARLIER, SENATOR LAIRD,
YOU MENTIONED, THAT THERE WAS
125,000,075 MILLION,
RESPECTIVELY. IN REDUCTIONS FOR
THE UC AND THE CSU THAT WERE
FOREGONE. THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
STILL BEING IMPLEMENTED. THEY'RE
PART OF THE 8% GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCIES ACROSS THE BOARD.
BUT BUT YOU WERE CORRECT IN
TERMS OF THE DEFERRAL AND THE
TIMING. SO I JUST WANTED TO,
I'LL TAKE THE CORRECT PART OF
YOUR STATEMENT. OKAY. THANK YOU.
AND, AND TO THAT POINT, THE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE 8%
UNALLOCATED, REDUCTIONS THAT THE
SEPARATE ENTITIES WILL COME UP
WITH, I PERSONALLY HAVE GRAVE
DOUBTS THAT THAT WILL TRULY
RESULT IN A FULL 8% UNLESS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO,
INSIST THAT EACH DEPARTMENT COME
UP WITH THAT NUMBER THAT WILL BE
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THAT. I
DON'T SEE ANY PART OF THE
OVERSIGHT. ON THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE IN THE BUDGET. SO IT'LL
TAKE ADDITIONAL WORK BEYOND THE
AGENCIES, ENTITIES THEMSELVES TO
COME UP WITH THAT. AND I'D ADD,
WITH REGARD TO SENATOR WAHAB'S
COMMENTS, RELATIVE TO ASSESSING
THE EFFICACY, SUCCESS OR LACK
THEREOF OF PROGRAMS THAT GO ON
AND ON AND ON, THERE REALLY
NEEDS TO BE SEPARATE ASSESSMENT
OF THAT AS OPPOSED TO SELF
ASSESSMENT, BECAUSE IF A
DEPARTMENT DECIDES THAT THEY
HAVE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
INEFFECTIVE, THAT MEANS THEY
ELIMINATE THEY NEED TO ELIMINATE
THE PROGRAM OR SUGGEST
MODIFICATIONS. BUT IF IT'S
ELIMINATE THAT CAUSES A
POTENTIAL REDUCTION IN
PERSONNEL, WHICH IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE ENTITIES
THEMSELVES TO GRAPPLE WITH. SO
THAT IS A PROBLEMATIC ASPECT OF
THE OF THE BUDGET, SENATOR
BECKER, THANK YOU. I JUST ONE
LAST QUICK COMMENT, AND I JUST
APPRECIATE EVERYONE WHO FOUGHT
TO INCLUDE, AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FINANCE IN THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DOLLARS IN THE, IN THE
BUDGET. I JUST HAPPENED TO SEE
LAST NIGHT A POST FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTY, AND SHE SHE SAYS
THAT, IT SAYS SHE SAYS SHE'LL
SAY IT AGAIN. THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA. LAND USE IS NOT A
BARRIER TO BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THIS IS IN REFERENCE TO
A 90 UNIT, DEVELOPMENT THAT'S
BETWEEN 30 AND 80% OF AMI IN LOS
ALTOS, ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE
, REALLY CITIES PROBABLY IN THE
STATE, BUT SHE AT LEAST SHE SAYS
WE NOW WE NEED THE STARS ALIGN
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO SECURE AN
ALLOCATION OF TAX CREDITS THIS
YEAR. BEYOND THAT, WE NEED TO
RETHINK HOW WE FINANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE COUNTY
PUT UP ANOTHER 10 MILLION, BUT
NOW THEY HAVE TO PRAY THEY CAN
GET TAX CREDITS FROM, FROM
CALIFORNIA AT THE STATE LEVEL.
AND WE JUST NEED TO, I THINK
GOING FORWARD, BOTH OF THE MONEY
WE PUT INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND ALSO THE WAY WE FINANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, STILL THINGS
WE NEED TO WORK ON BETTER GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BECKER. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? WELL, I
HAVE A FEELING WE PROBABLY WILL
HAVE LOTS OF COMMENTS FROM THIS
POINT ON WITH, PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND, THAT'S WHAT WE WILL DO NOW
IS ENTERTAIN COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC. I SEE THE PROFESSOR
COMING FORWARD, GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIRMAN. ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY, WE
WANTED TO THANK THE THREE
PARTIES FOR MAINTAINING THE $5
BILLION INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. GOOD MORNING. JULIA LOPEZ
WITH GREENBERG TRAURIG, ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
TO END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. SO ON
BEHALF OF THEM AND THE ENTIRE
VOCA ADVOCACY ALLIANCE, I WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP GRATITUDE TO
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR
INCLUDING 103 MILLION IN FUNDING
FOR CRIME VICTIM SERVICES IN THE
FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR. THESE FUNDS WILL
PREVENT DEVASTATING CUTS AND
ENSUE THAT VICTIM SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN EVERY PART OF THE
STATE CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE
SURVIVORS. REACHING OUT FOR
HELP. THANK YOU FOR ENSURING
THAT SURVIVORS CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LIFE SAVING
SERVICES THEY NEED AND DESERVE.
HELLO, I'M RICHARD COWAN, DICK
COWAN. FOR ABOUT TEN YEARS I
SERVED AS YOUR SENATE APPOINTEE
TO THE HISTORIC STATE CAPITOL
COMMISSION. I LOVE THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. I WORKED ON IT WHEN I
CAME BACK FROM THE NAVY AND MY
MILITARY SERVICE. WHILE I WAS
THE CHAIR OF THE HISTORIC STATE
CAPITOL COMMISSION. THE
NON-DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS
REQUIRED TO BE SIGNED BY ALL OF
THE STATE EMPLOYEES AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF WORKING ON THE
CAPITOL ANNEX PROJECT AND SIGNED
BY ALL OF THE CONSULTANTS
WORKING ON THE PROJECT, STOPPED
US AT THE COMMISSION FROM
GETTING THE INFORMATION WE
WANTED TO GIVE OUR SUGGESTIONS
ON HOW THAT PROJECT COULD COST
LESS AND BE A BETTER PROJECT. SO
I RESIGNED THE COMMISSION AND
BECAUSE OF THOSE NON-DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS, THE VOLUNTEERS I
TEAMED UP WITH LITTLE OLD LADIES
IN TENNIS SHOES. LITTLE OLD
GUYS, WITH THEIR BELTS UP AROUND
OUR OUR SHOULDERS, PICKED UP OUR
MONEY $50, $25, $10. AND WE
HIRED, SEQUA CONSULTANT AND A
SEQUA ATTORNEY AND GRAPHIC
ARTIST TO DRAW UP OUR BETTER
IDEAS FOR THE CAPITOL ANNEX
PROJECT, BECAUSE THE STAFF OF
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE TOLD
US THAT'S THE AVENUE WE HAD TO
USE. IT COST US MONEY. IT WAS
HARD. IT WAS HARD TO ROUND UP
VOLUNTEERS WHO COULD UNDERSTAND
THAT. BUT WE DID IT. AND SO FOR
FOUR YEARS WE FOLLOWED WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF TOLD US TO DO
USE SEQUA TO GIVE OUR BETTER
IDEAS ABOUT HOW THE PROJECT
COULD BE IMPROVED. SATURDAY, AN
AMENDMENT CAME UP PROPOSING TO
ELIMINATE SEQUA REQUIREMENT FOR
THE CAPITOL ANNEX PROJECT. I
URGE YOU TODAY TO OPPOSE THAT,
TO TAKE THAT REQUIREMENT OUT,
THERE NEED NO BE NO DELAY. OUR.
COULD YOU WORK TOWARDS YOUR
CONCLUSION? YES. OUR ATTORNEY
WAS WORKING WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S ATTORNEY ON A
SETTLEMENT OF THE TWO SUITS, AND
SHE STOPPED WHEN SHE SAW THIS
AMENDMENT DROPPED INTO THE BILL.
PLEASE TAKE IT OUT BEFORE YOU
PASS AB 174. THANK YOU, IF WE
COULD, BE SOMEWHAT ECONOMIC IN
OUR COMMENTS, WOULD VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT. YES, SENATOR
NILO LAREE STETSON, REPRESENTING
PRESERVATION SOCIETY. WE TOO,
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS. I'M WEARING TWO HATS
TODAY. I'M REPRESENTING THE
PRESERVATION SOCIETY, AND I'M
ALSO A PLAINTIFF WITH SAVE THE
CAPITOL. SAVE THE TREES. I KNOW
SENATOR LAIRD FROM LAST YEAR. WE
STARTED NEGOTIATIONS. THEN ON
THIS PROCESS TO REACH A
CONCLUSION THAT WAS SATISFACTORY
TO EVERYBODY. AND SINCE APRIL
11TH, THE FOCUS HAS BEEN ON AN
APPEAL THAT WE WON. THAT WOULD
SHUT DOWN CONSTRUCTION IN JULY.
WE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT. WE
TOLD THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
ATTORNEY WE WANTED TO START
NEGOTIATIONS, AND WE'VE BEEN
NEGOTIATING SINCE APRIL AND
WE'VE NARROWED IT DOWN TO ONLY
THE WEST LAWN PRESERVE, THE WEST
LAWN. THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
SAYS THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BUILD
ON THE WEST LAWN. THEN LET'S PUT
IT INTO LEGISLATION OR AN
AGREEMENT. SO WE WERE
NEGOTIATING. WE SENT A LETTER.
AND IN OUR LETTER WE SHOW THE
ATTORNEY'S LETTER TO THE AG
SAYING, LET'S GET THIS DONE BY
THE END OF JUNE. ALL OF A
SUDDEN, THIS, THIS EXEMPTION
SHOWS UP AND WE'RE CONFUSED. SO
AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER SAID, IF
YOU COULD WORK TO YOUR
CONCLUSION, PLEASE. SO MY
CONCLUSION IS AMEND AB 174 TO
INCLUDE LANGUAGE THAT PROTECTS
THE WEST SIDE. IF THAT'S DONE
AND THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD, ALL
LITIGATION WOULD BE DROPPED.
THAT WOULD STOP THE ANNEX
CONSTRUCTION. IT WOULD BE A WIN
WIN FOR EVERYBODY. THE GARAGE
COULD GO FORWARD. THE ANNEX
BUILDING WOULD GO FORWARD. THANK
YOU. AND THE WEST LAWN WOULD BE
PRESERVED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. REBECCA GONZALES
WITH THE WESTERN LAW, WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY, WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR
PROTECTING SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
IN THE BUDGET AND FOR INCLUDING
LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET TO
REIMAGINE CALWORKS TO BE MORE
FAMILY CENTERED AND LESS
PUNITIVE. WE ALSO ARE GRATEFUL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS NOT
REPEATED THE MISTAKES FROM THE
PAST, DURING THE LAST RECESSION
WHERE DEEP CUTS WERE MADE TO
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND IT TOOK
OVER A DECADE TO RECOVER, WE
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIPS AND
THE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
BOTH HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION, AND WE
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR
PROTECTING THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, KIM LEWIS, ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN, NOW, I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR PRESERVING OUR HUMAN
SAFETY NET, PARTICULARLY OUR
HOME VISITING PROGRAM, THE
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE, AND
MOST ESPECIALLY FORS. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH, WE'RE
GREATLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ROUND SIX FUNDING AND FOUR YEAR
CLEANUP IN THE TRAILER. BILL AND
ENSURING THAT INTERIM HOUSING
SOLUTIONS FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS CAN BE
BUILT IN FUTURE ROUNDS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. JUSTIN GARRETT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES CSAC, IS
GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE FINAL
BUDGET AGREEMENT THAT PROTECTS
CORE SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND
APPRECIATES THIS COMMITTEE'S
LEADERSHIP IN MAKING THAT A
REALITY, PRESERVING FUNDING FOR
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH, PROVIDING A NEW
ROUND OF HOMELESSNESS FUNDING
FOR HAP, SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
FOR VICTIMS OF CRIME AND THE TWO
ACTIONS ON THE ERAF ITEMS WILL
ALL HELP COUNTIES DELIVER
SERVICES TO VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL THIS IN
THE BUDGET BILLS. AND THANK YOU
AGAIN. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MICHELLE MCKAY UNDERWOOD, ON
BEHALF OF NEARLY ALL OF THE 60
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THAT
SUCCESSFULLY APPLIED FOR THE
LOCAL GRANTS UNDER THE INCLUSIVE
EARLY EDUCATION EXPANSION
PROGRAM FUNDS, THESE ARE FUNDS
FOR INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENTS FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
SO THAT THEY CAN LEARN AND GROW
AND PLAY ALONG THEIR GENERAL
EDUCATION PEERS, SO FIRST,
GRATITUDE AND SECONDLY, AN ASK,
FIRST, THE GRATITUDE IS THE
RESTORATION OF $100 MILLION OF
THOSE FUNDS STARTED OUT AT 250,
WENT TO ZERO. AND NOW IN THE
FINAL BUDGET $100 MILLION. SO
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT
RESTORATION. THE REQUEST IS THAT
ALL THAT $100 MILLION BE
DEDICATED FOR THOSE LEAS THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES THAT SUCCESSFULLY
APPLIED FOR THOSE FUNDS. IF ALL
THE DOLLARS WERE APPLIED TO
THOSE GRANTS, THEY'D GET ABOUT
85% OR SO OF WHAT THEY APPLIED
FOR. WE THINK THAT THEY CAN
BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN WHAT
THEY'D PLANNED AND THAT LOWERED
AMOUNT. IF IT IS SPLIT BETWEEN
THE THOSE DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES AND STATE LEVEL
ACTIVITIES, WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THEIR PLANS WITH FIDELITY. SO WE
ASK WITHOUT PREJUDICE TO THE
STATE LEVEL ACTIVITIES, THAT ALL
THOSE FUNDS BE DEDICATED TO THE
LOCAL GRANTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING ALCHEMY GRAHAM
HERE WITH TWO HATS ON, STARTING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CITY
TRANSPORTATION INITIATIVE. JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
GRATITUDE FOR RESTORING FUNDING
FOR THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM AND FOR THE COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE THAT FUNDING IN
FUTURE OUT YEARS WITH MY OTHER
HAT ON, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION. WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR DEEP GRATITUDE AS
WELL FOR RESTORING, EXCUSE ME,
MAINTAINING THE 5.1 BILLION IN
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC TRANSIT.
THANK YOU. HI. BRANDON TATE WITH
THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH EQUITY
COALITION. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MEMBERS AND STAFF
FOR RESTORING THE FUNDING OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY FOR THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE, AS WELL AS
THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNDING. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
IT'S GOING TO MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES, AND MANY OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. THANK
YOU. MORNING, TIM MADDEN,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS.
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF BEING INCLUDED
IN THE MCO TAX FOR PRO-RATA RATE
INCREASES, SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
SMALLER BUCKET FOR THE 2425 YEAR
TO INCLUDE EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
WILL GO A LONG WAYS TO
BUTTRESSING OUR EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. HI, KATIE HARDMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION K¾T IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSITION 98
PACKAGE, AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK. THANKS GOOD MORNING,
SENATORS PAMELA GIBBS,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. WE
FIRST OF ALL, I'D LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR REMARKS WITH SENATOR LAIRD,
THE CHAIR OF THE EDUCATION
SUBCOMMITTEE, AND APPRECIATE AND
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ALL OF THEIR
SUPPORT THIS YEAR. IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME, I'D LIKE TO
ALIGN MY REMARKS WITH THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION FOR THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM. LACO IS ONE
OF THE APPLICANTS AS WELL AS
SOME OF OUR DELICATE AGENCIES
AND PARTNERS IN THE COUNTY. SO
WE URGE YOU TO FULLY FUND THE
MONEY TO THE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES SO THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK THIS
YEAR. GOOD MORNING. JOHAN
CARDENAS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH NETWORK, WE
WANT TO TAKE THE THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
PRESERVING CORE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS. FIRST, WE
APPRECIATE RATE INCREASES FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS. WE'RE
ALSO THRILLED FOR IN-HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES WILL NOT BE
ELIMINATED FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED.
AND LASTLY, WE THANK YOU FOR
PRESERVING THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM AND A MAJORITY OF THE
FUNDING FOR THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, WE
APPRECIATE STATE POLICYMAKERS
FOR UPLIFTING EQUITY AS A VALUE
IN THIS BUDGET. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, SENATORS JORDAN LINDSEY
WITH THE ARC OF CALIFORNIA AND
ARC UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY,
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE ARE VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT
THERE IS A SIX MONTH DELAY IN
THE RATE IMPLEMENTATION THAT HAS
BEEN PROMISED, AND THAT IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS BODY HAS DONE A LOT OF WORK
TO IMPROVE IT. FROM THE 12 MONTH
DELAY PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
NONETHELESS, THAT IS A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS BEING
CUT AND WILL NOT COME BACK TO
CALIFORNIANS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS ROLLER COASTER RIDE OF
FUNDING FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES NEEDS
TO COME TO A STOP THIS YEAR,
BEING A PERFECT, PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF IT. WE BELIEVE OUR WORK
BEGINS NOW ON CREATING A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE, AND
WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL WORK WITH
US ON THAT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MENGIBAR, FOR THE COMMENTS
REGARDING THE DISAPPOINTMENT, AS
WELL AS ACKNOWLEDGING THE
RESTORATION OF THE DENTAL GRANT.
THAT IS IMPORTANT. THANK YOU.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA. I AM GOING TO BE
CAPTURING OUR APPRECIATION ON
BEHALF OF 700,000 MEMBERS. SO IF
I MISS SOMETHING, IT DOESN'T
MEAN WE DON'T APPRECIATE IT. WE
HAVE THE LONG I BELIEVE
TECHNICAL TERM WAS PAINFUL
LETTER COMING AND THAT CAPTURES
ALL OF IT. BUT WE REALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE LEGISLATIVE
CONTRIBUTION TO A MORE BALANCED
APPROACH THAT PRESERVES THE
SAFETY NET AND NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS. WE KNOW THAT YOU
WORKED REALLY HARD TO PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY NET SERVICES, BUT
ALSO YOU SHOWED CONSIDERATION TO
THE WORKFORCE THAT DOES THOSE
SERVICES PROTECTING RATES AND
SLOTS AND CHILD CARE, WAIVING
LATE LAYOFFS IN K THROUGH 12 AND
SUPPLEMENTING THE CRUCIAL SUMMER
NET SUMMER BRIDGE, AS WELL AS
PROTECTING LABOR AGREEMENTS AND
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES FUNDING TIED
TO STAFFING IN IHS DIR AND IN
OUR COURTS. AND FINALLY, WE
THANK YOU AND THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR SECURING THE PATHWAY FOR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS TO ACHIEVE
THE HIGHEST MINIMUM WAGE IN THE
COUNTRY. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, SENATORS MALIK BYNUM
WITH UAW LOCAL 3930,
REPRESENTING OVER 180,000 HOME
CARE AND CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
ACROSS THE STATE. HAPPY TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BUDGET BILL. JOR
AB, SB 108 THAT INCLUDES
SUPPLEMENTAL LANGUAGE TO THE
THREE PARTY AGREEMENT PRESERVING
CORE SERVICES, INCLUDING THE
IHSS PROGRAM, AS WELL AS AB 160
AB, SB 163 THAT MAINTAINS THE
ALLOCATION OF OVER 11,000 CHILD
CARE SLOTS FOR OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS. WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
OVER LANGUAGE IN THE CHILD CARE
TRAILER BILL THAT CHANGES THE
CSP ELIGIBILITY TO INCLUDE TWO
YEAR OLDS, AS THIS MAY
UNINTENTIONALLY IMPEDE UPON OUR
PROVIDERS ABILITY TO CARE FOR
THESE CHILDREN, AND WE WOULD
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS WORK FOR
BOTH WORKFORCES. BUT
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CHALLENGE WITH THE HISTORIC
DEFICIT WE'RE THANKFUL TO YOU
ALL FOR PROTECTING THESE
PROGRAMS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
IMPROVING UPON THEM IN THE YEARS
TO COME. THANKS GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY
WITH ABC CALIFORNIA, WOULD LIKE
TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH SEIU
ON PROTECTION OF THE WORKFORCE,
AS WELL AS OUR AFFILIATE, AFSCME
LOCAL 3930 UW ON IHSS AND
CHILDCARE, I ALSO WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT, RELATED TO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
BUDGET. OUR MEMBERS THAT DO
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION AND
MAINTAIN CASES FOR CALWORKS HAVE
ALREADY HAD MANY CLIENT SERVICES
HALTED SINCE THE BUDGET CAME
OUT. SO WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR WORK TO PRESERVE WHAT
YOU COULD TO MAINTAIN PROGRAMS
WHICH ALLOW OUR MEMBERS TO SERVE
THE COMMUNITY. AND ALSO WANTED
TO NOTE THAT IN THE FUTURE, AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT ENSURING THAT
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT WISELY
AT CDCR, THERE'S A CHRONIC ABUSE
OF CONTRACTING OUT PUBLIC SECTOR
WORK TO OVERPAID CONTRACTORS TO
A TUNE OF HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, WITH THE AGENCY
COMING BACK EVERY YEAR TO ASK
FOR MORE TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO GO
TO THESE CONTRACTORS, ALL WHILE
THERE IS A MONTHLY RUNNING BAR
TAB OF FINES, WHICH IS NOW UP TO
$150 MILLION BECAUSE OF THE
AGENCY'S FAILURE TO ADDRESS
VACANCIES, WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN FUTURE YEARS TO
TAKE A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES AND
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND MEDICAL
WORKFORCE AT CDCR. THANK YOU.
HI, TIFFANY MORK, ON BEHALF OF
CFD, A UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS, WANTED
TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON PROPOSITION 98
FUNDING. THE èC COMPACT,
FUNDING THE UC LABOR CENTERS,
AND ALSO ENSURING STUDENTS HAVE
OFFICE HOURS AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. FINALLY, AS A NOTE, WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AT SOME POINT
$10 MILLION OR MORE FOR
FINANCIAL LITERACY SO THAT ALL
OUR STUDENTS IN THE STATE CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT VALUE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
ON THAT MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING,
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN, ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK ON
PROPOSITION 98 AND THE EFFORTS
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ITS STUDENTS IN A
DIFFICULT BUDGET YEAR. HOWEVER,
AS MEMBERS OF THE CAL GRANT
REFORM COALITION, WE ARE DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE EXCLUSION
OF CAL GRANT REFORM FROM THE
BUDGET. THIS WOULD BE A GAME
CHANGER FOR NON TRADITIONAL
STUDENTS AS WELL AS THOSE WITH
THE GREATEST NEEDS, AND WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY AND ENCOURAGE ITS
INCLUSION IN FUTURE BUDGETS.
GOOD MORNING, JACK ANDERSON WITH
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA,
REPRESENTING OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. WE WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR SINCERE GRATITUDE FOR THE
CONTINUED LEVEL OF COMMITMENT
FOR STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH, WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET ACT AGREEMENT. AND
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO BUDGET STAFF FOR
ROBUST ENGAGEMENT THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET PROCESS ON ITEMS
INCLUDING THE CCDF SYNDROMIC
SURVEILLANCE TRAILER BILL, AS
WELL AS THE TRANSFER OF THE
HEALTH CARE PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MARIA ROMO WITH THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER. WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE ADMINISTRATION
IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR FIRM
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT
CRITICAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS,
WHICH INCLUDE CHILD CARE, HOME
VISITING, THE EMERGENCY FOSTER
CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM AND CALWORKS
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN PROTECTED
DURING THIS VERY DIFFICULT
BUDGET YEAR. WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO EXPRESS HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE
FOR THE CONTINUED PROTECTION OF
OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDER PAY
RATES AS THE ADMINISTRATION
WORKS TO IMPLEMENT THE NEW COST
OF CARE RATE, PROTECTING THESE
INVESTMENTS MEANS THAT CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WILL STAY ONE
STEP CLOSER TO A WAGE AND
FAMILIES CAN ACCESS CRITICAL
SUPPORTS THAT ENABLE THEM TO
WORK, PUT FOOD ON THE TABLES AND
KEEP THEIR FAMILIES WHOLE. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MOLLY ROBSON
WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD,
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL THAT THIS
BUDGET INCLUDES INVESTMENTS IN
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE FROM THE MCO TAX. HOWEVER,
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS PART OF A
LARGER HEALTH SYSTEM, AND ONE
THIRD OF OUR HEALTH CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ALSO PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. SO WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THIS BUDGET
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE SUSTAINABLE
INVESTMENTS IN THE LARGER SYSTEM
TO INCLUDE PRIMARY CARE AND
COMMUNITY CLINICS, BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL
ON THOSE SUSTAINABLE, LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
MEDI-CAL PATIENTS. AND REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE PROTECTIONS TO
EXISTING SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AS
WELL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, DEREK LENNOX,
ON BEHALF OF THE 58 COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
FIRST, WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK ON THE
PROP 98 PACKAGE. WE THINK THIS
IS A GREAT DEAL FOR STUDENTS.
IT'S GOING TO REALLY SUPPORT THE
INVESTMENTS THAT YOU'VE MADE
OVER RECENT YEARS. I ALSO WANT
TO GIVE SPECIAL THANKS TO OUR
CHAIR OF SUB ONE, AND TO THE
COMMITTEE AS A WHOLE FOR THE
WORK ON THE EMERGENCY SCHOOL
CLOSURE LANGUAGE, WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN A SCHOOL EXPERIENCES
MATERIAL DECREASES IN ATTENDANCE
OR SCHOOL CLOSURES AS A RESULT
OF A NATURAL DISASTER? WE THINK
THAT THE FINAL LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET WAS REALLY RESONATING
WITH THE FIELD AS A WAY TO
ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO BETTER
PREPARE FOR THESE INEVITABLE
ENCLOSURES, OR CLOSURES, AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE WITH AND PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION TO STUDENTS. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEGAN BEAR
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS, I'LL ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY PREVIOUS
COLLEAGUE WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE
FOR THE PROP EIGHT PACKAGE. THIS
IS AN EXCELLENT DEAL FOR SCHOOLS
AND THIS BUDGET DEAL, AND ALSO
AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR THE
EMERGENCY CLOSURES, PROPOSAL AND
ALL THE WORK ON THAT, AMONG
OTHER THINGS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, KIMBERLY SANCHEZ WITH
ACTION CALIFORNIA, ALSO A PART
OF THE CAL GRANT COALITION,
THOUGH WE'RE GLAD TO SEE FUNDING
FOR FINANCIAL AID IN THE FINAL
BUDGET DEAL, WE'RE DISAPPOINTED
THAT NO FUNDING WAS INCLUDED TO
IMPLEMENT THE CAL GRANT REFORM
ACT OF 2022. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
FINAL INVESTMENTS FOR FINANCIAL
AID IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET LAYS
THE FOUNDATION TO COME BACK NEXT
YEAR TO FUND THESE IMPORTANT
REFORMS FOR CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
WE THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
YOUR EFFORTS TO FIND SOLUTIONS
FOR CAL GRANT REFORM, AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING WORKING
WITH YOU ALL IN THE GOVERNOR ON
IMPLEMENTING CAL GRANT. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
BRANDON MAKI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION, I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HELPING
TO KEEP SOME OF THE MCO MONEY,
FOR ITS INTENDED PURPOSES, WHICH
WAS TO INCREASE MEDI-CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT WAS A
RESTORATION FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. SO WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THAT, HOWEVER, WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THAT WE HAVE ONCE
AGAIN MISSED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE A ONCE IN A GENERATION
INVESTMENT INTO INCREASING
ACCESS TO MEDI-CAL RECIPIENTS
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONALLY, WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO, EXPRESS OUR DISAPPOINTMENT
ABOUT THE CUTTING OF THE GME
FUNDING THAT IS IN THE PROGRAM,
OR EXCUSE ME, THAT IS IN THIS
BUDGET, ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
WAS ALLOCATED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS
THE PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
WITHIN THE STATE AND ADDRESS THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THAT NEXT
YEAR. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
AS WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION, WANT TO
ALSO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH MANY
OF MY EDUCATION COLLEAGUES. AND
THANK YOU FOR THE PROPOSITION 98
PACKAGE. WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL
THAT EDUCATION FUNDING IS
PROTECTED IN OUR STUDENTS WILL
BE RECEIVING, THE NECESSARY
FUNDING AND EDUCATION THAT THEY
DESERVE. ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE, PROTECTION, PROTECTING
OUR CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES FROM
SUMMER LAYOFF, SUMMER IS A VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT TIME FOR OUR
MEMBERS, SO I ALSO WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE SUMMER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
IS A LIFELINE IN THE SUMMERTIME
FOR OUR MEMBERS. SO VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF ALL YOUR WORK ON
THOSE. THANK YOU. JACKIE
GONZALEZ WITH IMMIGRANT DEFENSE
ADVOCATES. I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
DEEP APPRECIATION TO THIS,
COMMITTEE FOR LISTENING
COMPASSIONATELY TO THE ISSUES
RELATED TO IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES, IN PARTICULAR THE
LEGAL SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT
WERE ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
PRESERVATION OF THE TPS FUNDS
AND THE CSU LEGAL SERVICES
FUNDS. WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE
MORE THAN JUST LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS. THEY'RE ECONOMIC
STABILITY AND MOBILITY. ANY TIME
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN
PROTECT A FAMILY OR A PERSON
FROM DEPORTATION, THEY ALSO
STABILIZE A FAMILY AND A
COMMUNITY. ANY TIME WE CAN MAKE
A STUDENT A LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENT AND CITIZEN OF THIS
GREAT STATE, THEY CONTRIBUTE
BACK TO OUR ECONOMY. WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED TO NOT SEE ANY
DOLLARS SET ASIDE FOR
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN. IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THAT
POPULATION TO COME HERE AND
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES,
UNDERSTANDABLY. BUT THAT ISSUE
REMAINS A VERY BIG ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA, AND I WOULD URGE
THIS LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER HOW
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO PRESERVE
EVEN A SCALED BACK VERSION OF
THAT PROGRAM BEFORE THIS YEAR IS
OVER. THANK YOU AGAIN. TRIBES.
GOOD MORNING. EDSON PEREZ WITH
ADVANCED ENERGY UNITED. WE
WANTED TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION
FOR THE FLEXIBILITY LANGUAGE
THAT WAS PUT IN THE BUDGET BILL
AROUND THE DEMAND SIDE, GRID
SUPPORT PROGRAM TO KEEP THE
DISTRIBUTED ELECTRICITY BACKUP
ASSETS PROGRAM AFLOAT. THIS THIS
YEAR, BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
REALLY CRITICAL TO KEEP OUR OUR
GRID AFLOAT AND AVOID BLACKOUTS
DURING TIMES OF EMERGENCY USING
CLEAN, DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
INSTEAD OF WHAT WE CURRENTLY
RELY ON, WHICH ARE, IS DIRTY
ENERGY EXPENSIVE, POLLUTING
ENERGY PLANTS. SO WE DID WANT TO
EXPRESS DISAPPOINTMENT ABOUT THE
CUTS THAT THAT END UP GOING
THROUGH FOR BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND WANTED TO, EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR INCREASING FUNDING
OR ALLOCATING FURTHER GRF
RESOURCES TO THESE TWO PROGRAMS
TO GET US THROUGH TIMES OF
EMERGENCY, AGAIN WITH CLEAN
ENERGY. THANK YOU. THAT APPEARS
TO BE ALL OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
THAT HAS ANYTHING TO SAY? THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SEEING NO ONE
COME FORWARD. BRING IT BACK ONCE
MORE TO THE COMMITTEE. IF
ANYBODY HAS ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, SEEING
NONE, WE WILL DIVE INTO THE
VOTING. TAKING THEM, THE ITEMS
ONE BY ONE. DO I HAVE A MOTION
ON AB 108? SO MOVE. MOVED BY
SENATOR LAIRD. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. IT'S A MAN THING. MAYBE
108. THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
SENATORS. WIENER NILO. NO. NILO.
NO. BECKER HI. BECKER. I BLAKE
SPEAR. HE CAN'T HEAR IN THAT
EAR. BLAKE. SPEAR I CORTEZ, I
CORTEZ, I DOLLY. NO! DOLLY! NO!
DURAZZO EGGMAN DOES THE FIRST
ONE. GROVE. YES. GROVE. NO LAIRD
I LAIRD I MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN A NEWMAN I PADILLA. ROTH
A ROTH I SATO NO SATO NO.
SKINNER. SKINNER I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
WAHAB I WAHAB I WILK. NO. WILK.
NO. SUBMARINES. THAT'S THE ONLY
PLACE WE CAN GO. WE WILL HOLD
THAT OPEN, MOTION, PLEASE, ON AB
109. SO MOVED, WHO WAS THAT?
ROTH, MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB 109. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. SENATORS
WIENER NILO NØ. NILO NÓ. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER BLAKE.
SPEER I CORTESE I CORTESE I.
DOLLY. DOLLY NO. DURAZZO EGGMAN.
GROVE. GROVE. NO. LAIRD. LAIRD I
MENJIVAR. MENJIVAR I NEWMAN I
NEWMAN I PADILLA. ROTH I ROTH I
SATO. SATO NO. SKINNER. SKINNER
I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I SMILED.
CUEVAS I WAHAB I WAHAB I WILK.
C  WILK. NO. OKAY, WE WILL HOLD
THAT OPEN, MOTION ON AB 153.
MOVED NÓ. SENATOR CORTEZ MOVES
AB 153. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
153. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER NILO. APO. NO.
MILO. NO. BECKER I BECKER I
BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE SPEAR I
CORTEZ THREE I CORTEZ I DOLLY.
DOLLY. NO. TERRAZZO EGGMAN.
GROVE. NO. GROVE. NO LAIRD.
LAIRD I MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN I NEWMAN I PADILLA. ROTH.
ROTH I CIERTO. CIERTO. NO.
SKINNER. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS. SMALL. CUEVAS I WAHAB I
WAHAB I WILK. NO WILK. NO AND WE
WILL HOLD THAT OPEN, IT WAS JUST
POINTED OUT TO ME THAT ON EACH
OF THE MOTIONS THAT, THERE WAS
MORE THAN ONE PERSON THAT
OFFERED THE MOTION, AND, THERE
WAS A WOMAN OR TWO ON MY LEFT
SIDE AND A MAN OR TWO ON MY
RIGHT SIDE. AND EACH TIME I
CHOSE THE MAN, I ASSURE YOU, I
AM NOT A MISOGYNIST. I AM DEAF
IN MY LEFT EAR. I APOLOGIZE.
IT'S TRUE. I AM TO. SO, NOW
LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON AB 155.
LOOK, LOOK OVER THIS WAY,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS MOVES
AB 155. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
155 THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER NILO I NILO I.
BECKER I BECKER I BLAKE. SPEAR I
BLAKE. SPEAR I CORTEZ I CORTEZ I
DOLLY DURAZZO. EGGMAN GROVE.
GROVE I LAIRD, LAIRD I MENGIBAR.
MENJIVAR I NEWMAN A NEWMAN I
PADILLA I PADILLA I ROTH, ROTH I
SATO. SKINNER I SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I SMALL CUEVAS I WAHAB
NIGH. WAHAB I WILK I WILK I. WE
WILL HOLD THAT OPEN. ALSO.
NOTICE HOW GENEROUS I'M BEING TO
OUR CHAIR HOLDING THESE OPEN FOR
OUR CHAIR. YES, I WILL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION ON AB 156. MOVE THE
BILL, SENATOR WAHAB MOVES AB
156. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
156. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER. NILO. NØ. NILO
NÓ. BECKER. BECKER I BLAKE.
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR I CORTEZ.
DOLLY. DOLLY. NO DURAZO. EGGMAN
GROVE. NO. GROVE. NO LAIRD.
LAIRD I MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN I NEWMAN I PADILLA.
PADILLA I ROTH. ROTH I CIERTO.
SERATO NO. SKINNER I SKINNER I
SMALL CUEVAS. WAHAB I WAHAB I
WILK. NO. WILK. NO. WE WILL HOLD
THAT ITEM OPEN, I WILL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION. MR. CHAIR, I WOULD, I
WOULD I Ó SMALL CUEVAS I AM I
OWNER IS COURTESY ON IT. JUST
MAKING SURE I HEARD, WILK. I
THOUGHT THAT WAS THE END OF THE
ALPHABET. I APOLOGIZE, IT IS.
OKAY. YOU YOU'VE RECORDED,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS VOTE?
YES. OKAY. SENATOR CORTEZ. AYE.
SENATOR CORTEZ. AYE. THANK YOU.
NO WORRIES, ANY 159, 159.
SENATOR MENGIBAR MOVES, 159 CALL
THE ROLL. AB 159. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS. SENATORS WIENER.
NILO. NO NILO. NO BECKER. BECKER
I BLAKESBERG BLAKE. SPEAR I
CORTEZ I CORTEZ I. DOLLY. DOLLY!
NO DURAZO. EGGMAN GROVE. GROVE.
NO. LAIRD LAIRD I MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
PADILLA. PADILLA I ROTH A ROTH I
CIERTO CIERTO. NO SKINNER.
SKINNER I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WAHAB I
WAHAB I WILK. NO. WILK. NO WE
WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN. I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON AB 164
MOVES FOR MOVES, SENATOR
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR MOVES, AB 160,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB 160. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. SENATORS
WIENER. NILO. NØ. NILO NO.
BECKER. BECKER I BLAKESBERG
BLAKE. SPEAR I CORTEZ I CORTEZ I
. DOLLY. DOLLY! NO. DURAZO
EGGMAN. GROVE GROVE NO. LAIRD.
LAIRD I MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN. ALL RIGHT. NEWMAN I
PADILLA. PADILLA I ROTH, ROTH I
SATO. NO SATO. NO. SKINNER I
SKINNER, SKINNER I SMALL. CUEVAS
SMALL. CUEVAS I WAHAB I WAHAB I
WILK NO. WILK NO. WE'LL HOLD
THAT OPEN, MOTION ON AB ONE.
MOVE. APPROVAL OH, YOU GOT A
REPUBLICAN? I BEG YOUR PARDON?
MOVE! APPROVAL. AB 161. THE
MOTION IS BY SENATOR SATO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB 161. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. SENATORS
WIENER NILO. I NILO I BECKER
HIGH. BECKER I BLAKE. SPEAR.
BLAKE. SPEAR I CORTEZ I CORTEZ I
DOLLY, DOLLY I DURAZZO. EGGMAN.
GROVE. GROVE I LAIRD. LAIRD I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN I
NEWMAN I PADILLA. PADILLA I ROTH
ROTH I CIERTO I SATO I SKINNER I
SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS SMALL
CUEVAS I WAHAB I WAHAB I WILK, I
WILK I 16 ZERO. WE WILL HOLD
THAT ITEM OPEN. I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON AB 162. MOVED BY
SENATOR MOVED. MOVE, MOVE.
MOVED. IT IS MOVED BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB 162, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER. NILO. NØ. NILO
NO BECKER I BECKER I BLAKESBERG.
HI. BLAKE. SPEAR I CORTEZ I
CORTEZ I DOLLY. DOLLY. NO
DURAZO. EGGMAN GROVE. GROVE. NO
LAIRD. LAIRD I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
PADILLA. PADILLA I ROTH I ROTH I
CIERTO. CIERTO. NO SKINNER.
SKINNER I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
SMALL. CUEVAS I WAHAB I WAHAB I
WILK. NO. WILK. NO 11-3. I WILL
HOLD IT OVER. WILL HOLD THAT,
162. OPEN MOTION ON. 163. I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION, SENATOR
CORTEZ MOVES 163. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ÁP 163. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS. SENATORS WIENER!
NILO. NO NILO. NO BECKER. ALL
RIGHT. BECKER I BLAKESBERG I
BLAKESBERG I CORTEZ I CORTEZ, I
DOLLY. DOLLY! NO. DURAZO EGGMAN.
GROVE GROVE. NO. LAIRD. LAIRD I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN I
NEWMAN I PADILLA. PADILLA I
ROTH. ROTH I CIERTO. NO. CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER. SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WAHAB I WILK. NO. WILK.
NO 11 FIVE. WE WILL HOLD THAT
ITEM OPEN. I WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON A B 164. WHO SAID MOVE
SOMEWHERE ON THAT SIDE, SENATOR
PADILLA MOVES, AB 164, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB 164. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS. SENATORS WIENER
NILO NØ. NILO. NO. BECKER.
BECKER I BLAKESBERG. HI, BLAKE.
SPEAR I CORTEZ I CORTEZ I.
DOLLY. DOLLY! NO. DURAZO EGGMAN.
GROVE. GROVE. NO. LAIRD. LAIRD I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN. I
NEWMAN I PADILLA. PADILLA I ROTH
. ROTH I CIERTO. NO. SATO. NO.
SKINNER. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS. SMALL. CUEVAS I WAHAB.
WAHHAB I WILK. NO WILK. NO 11
FIVE. WE'LL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON AB
166. WHO MOVED THE BILL, SENATOR
PADILLA, SENATOR PADILLA MOVES
AB 166. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
166, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER. NILO. NO NILO.
NO. BECKER I BECKER I BLAKE.
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR I CORTEZ I
CORTEZ I. DOLLY DOLLY NO DURAZO.
EGGMAN GROVE. LAIRD LAIRD I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I PADILLA. PADILLA I ROS.
HI. ROTH I CIERTO NO SATO, NO.
SKINNER. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS. SMALL. CUEVAS I WAHAB I
WAHAB I WILK. NO. WILK NO. 11
FOUR WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN. I
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON AB
168 MOVED. SENATOR CORTEZ MOVES
AB 168. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
168. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER NILO NÓ, NILO NÓ
. BECKER. BECKER I BLAKE. SPEAR.
BLAKE. SPEAR. I CORTEZ A CORTEZ
I DOLLY. DURAZO EGGMAN. NO
DOLLY, NO. DURAZO EGGMAN. GROVE.
NO GROVE NO. LAIRD LAIRD I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN I
NEWMAN I PADILLA. PADILLA I
ROTH. ROTH I SATO. NO SATO. NO.
SKINNER I SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS I SMALL. CUEVAS I WAHAB I
WAHAB I WILK. NO. WILK. NO. IT'S
10 TO 5. WE WILL HOLD THAT ITEM.
OPEN A B 169. I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. SENATOR CORTEZ MOVES AB
169. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
169. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER NILO NOT VOTING.
BECKER. BECKER I BLAKE. SPEAR.
BLAKE. SPEAR I CORTEZ I CORTEZ
I. DOLLY DURAZO. EGGMAN GROVE.
GROVE I LAIRD. LAIRD I MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN A NEWMAN I
PADILLA. PADILLA I ROTH I ROTH I
SATO. SKINNER. SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS. WAHAB I. WAHAB I WILK I
WILK I. COORDINATOR WILL HOLD
THAT ONE OPEN. MILITANT, THE
NEXT SENATOR. SENATOR WAHAB
MOVES AB 170. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AB 170. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS. SENATORS WIENER NILO. NO
NILO. NO. BECKER I BECKER I
BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR I
CORTEZ I CORTEZ I. DOLLY DOLLY.
NO. DURAZO EGGMAN. GROVE LAIRD.
LAIRD I MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN I NEWMAN I PADILLA.
PADILLA I ROTH I ROTH I SATO NO
SATO, NO SKINNER. SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS. SMALL. CUEVAS I
WAHAB. WAHHAB I WILK. NO WILK.
NO. I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU
GOT ME ON THE LAST ONE. YES,
YES, YES, I THE ONE CURSING LIKE
A SAILOR THèC BIDEN FIRST AND
THEN YOU. REVENUE FOR WE WILL
HOLD THAT ONE OPEN. I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION NOW ON AB 171
MOVE MOVED BY SENATOR CORTEZ FOR
AB 171. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
171. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER NILO NØ. NILO
NÓ. BECKER. BECKER I BLAKE.
SPEAR BLAKE. SPEAR I CORTEZ I
CORTEZ I. DOLLY. DOLLY. NO
DURAZZO. DURAZZO I EGGMAN.
GROVE. LAIRD LAIRD I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN. HIGH NEWMAN I
PADILLA I PADILLA I ROTH. ROTH I
CIERTO. NO. SATO. NO. SKINNER.
SKINNER I SMALL. CUEVAS. SMALL
CUEVAS I WAHAB I WAHAB I WILK.
NØ. WILK. NO 12 FOUR. WE WILL
HOLD THAT ONE OPEN, I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION NOW ON AB
173. SO MOVED. THAT WAS SENATOR
BECKER, SENATOR BECKER MOVES AB
173. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
173. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER NILO NÓ, NILO NÓ
BECKER A BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. I CORTEZ A
CORTEZ. AYE. DOLLY DOLLY. NO.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO DURAZZO I
EGGMAN. GROVE. NO GROVE. NO.
LAIRD. LAIRD I MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN I NEWMAN I
PADILLA. PADILLA I ROTH. ROTH I
CIERTO. NO. SATO. NO. SKINNER.
SKINNER I SMALL. CUEVAS. SMALL.
CUEVAS I WAHAB I WAHAB I WILK.
NÓ. WILK NO. OH FIVE. WE WILL
HOLD THAT ONE OPEN AND I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. NOW ON AB
174. MOVE THE VOTE, SENATOR
WAHAB MOVES AB 174. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB 174. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED. SENATORS WIENER.
NILO. NO NILO. NO. BECKER I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG BLAKE. SPEAR
I CORTEZ I CORTEZ I. DOLLY.
DOLLY! NO DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
EGGMAN. GROVE. NO. GROVE. NO.
LAIRD LAIRD I MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR
I NEWMAN A NEWMAN I PADILLA.
PADILLA I ROTH I ROTH I SATO NO
SATO. NO. SKINNER. SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS. SMALL. CUEVAS I
WAHAB I WAHAB I WILK. NO. WILK.
NO 12 FIVE. WE WILL HOLD THAT
ITEM OPEN. AND LAST, BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST, I'LL ACCEPT
A MOTION ON AB 175. SO MOVED.
MOVED BY SENATOR CORTEZ, PLEASE.
AB 175, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
175, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
SENATORS WIENER NILO NOT VOTING.
BECKER, A BECKER I BREAKSPEAR
BREAKSPEAR I CORTEZ I CORTEZ I.
DOLLY. NO DOLLY. NO. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I EGGMAN. GROVE GROVE
NO. LAIRD HÌNH. LAIRD I MENGIBAR
I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN A NEWMAN I
PADILLA. PADILLA I ROTH I ROTH I
SATO NO SATO, NO. SKINNER I
SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS SMALL.
CUEVAS I WAHAB I WAHAB I WILK.
NO. WILK. NO CORRECT. CAN I GO I
NODA I ON 174. SORRY, I LOST
TRACK. WE WAIT FOR SENATOR
GROVE. NO TO I AB 174 GROVE. NO
TO I THANK YOU. THAT WAS A NEW
ONE FOR ME. WE JUST. WHOEVER
TURNED MY MIC OFF WHEN I STARTED
TALKING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT. HAVING A SIDE
CONVERSATION. WE WILL OPEN THE
ROLL FOR, GO THROUGH THE BILLS.
FOR THOSE THAT HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO VOTE YET. STARTING WITH, AB
108.
I. I THINK I'M THE ONE.
EVERYTHING.
THAT. SO CALLING ANY MEMBERS OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE THAT ARE
NOT HERE, WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE BILLS AGAIN FOR
EVERYBODY TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE. GOOD, WE'LL WAIT A
COUPLE OF MINUTES FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO FILL SEATS. DOWN SEE
HOW MANY FOLKS THERE ARE NOT.
WE CAN GO BACK THROUGH THE BILLS
AGAIN. FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE.
THAT WERE NOT ABLE TO VOTE. AND
ONCE WE GET THROUGH THOSE THAT
ARE HERE, WE WILL RECESS. THEN
FOR ANY THAT CAN'T BE HERE RIGHT
NOW. SO, MOVING THROUGH THE
BILLS, STARTING WITH AB 108, AB
108 SENATORS WIENER DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I. EGGMAN PADILLA.
PADILLA I.
KEEP THAT ONE OPEN. STILL NOW,
AB 109, I DO NOT. I WILL ASK FOR
. SORRY, I DIDN'T. I DIDN'T, AND
IF NOT, I JUST. MY VOTE IS.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW. AB 109
SENATORS WIENER DURAZZO. DURAZZO
I EGGMAN. PADILLA. PADILLA I.
CONTINUE TO HOLD THAT OPEN. AB
153. AB 153. SENATORS. WIENER
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. I PADILLA.
PADILLA I HOLD THAT ONE OPEN,
CONTINUE TO HOLD THAT OPEN. AB
155. NOW AB 155. SENATORS.
WIENER HI. WIENER. I DOLLY.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO I. EGGMAN
SEYARTO. AND OUR CHAIR HAS
RETURNED. OKAY SIR. WHAT'S THE
VOTE ON THAT BILL? WE'RE MISSING
NUMBERS.
THERE NEEDS TO SOME CATCH UP. TO
WHAT? I'M SORRY. OKAY. THANK
YOU, EVERYONE AND COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU. I'M BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY. AND THANK YOU TO THE
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU TO THE
VICE CHAIR FOR FACILITATING
EVERYTHING. I APPRECIATE IT.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO START BACK
AT THE TOP AND CLOSE OUT EACH OF
THESE ITEMS, BECAUSE I THINK WE
HAVE EVERYONE HERE NOW WHO NEEDS
TO VOTE, SO WE'LL START WITH
ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 108, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATORS WIENER. AYE. WIENER.
AYE SENATOR EGGMAN, I'M OFF.
THANK YOU. YEAH. 13 TO 5. 13 TO
5. THAT VOTE IS 13 TO 5, AND THE
BILL IS OUT, WE'LL NEXT GO TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO. AB 109, PLEASE
CALL THE OPPOSITE MEMBERS, MAYBE
109 SENATORS. WIENER. AYE.
WIENER AYE. EGGMAN OKAY, THE
VOTE IS 13 TO 5. THE BILL IS
OUT. ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 153.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB 153 SENATORS WIENER. AYE.
WIENER. AYE EGGMAN. OKAY, THE
VOTE IS 13 TO 5. THE BILL IS
OUT. ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 155.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATORS. EGGMAN.
OKAY. THE VOTE IS 16. I VOTED ON
THAT BEFORE I 16. NOTHING. THE
BILL IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER FIVE,
AB 156. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MAY BE 156 SENATORS.
WIENER AYE. WIENER. AYE.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN
SHE'S NOT COMING BACK. SHE'S NOT
COMING BACK. NO, I DON'T THINK
SHE'S NOT OKAY. YEAH THE VOTE IS
13 TO 5. THE BILL IS OUT. ITEM
NUMBER SIX, AB 159. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATORS
WIENER. AYE WIENER AYE. DURAZZO
I DURAZZO I EGGMAN. 1313 TO 5.
THAT BILL IS OUT. WE NEXT GO TO
NUMBER SEVEN AB 160, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYBE 160
SENATORS. WIENER AYE. WIENER.
AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN 1313 TO 5. THAT BILL IS
OUT. ONE ZERO TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT, AB 161. PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. MAYBE 161.
SENATORS WIENER. AYE. WIENER.
AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN 18 ZERO OKAY. 18 ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT, ONE NEXT, GO
TO ITEM NUMBER NINE. AB 162.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB 162. SENATORS WIENER. AYE.
WIENER AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. GOT 13 513 TO 5.
THAT BILL IS OUT, ITEM NUMBER
TEN. AB 163. PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. AB 163
SENATORS WIENER WIENER. AYE
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AND 13 FIVE. 13 TO 5. THE BILL
IS OUT, NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER 11,
AB 164. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AB 164 SENATORS WIENER.
AYE. WIENER AYE. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN 13 513 TO
5. THAT BILL IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER
12 AB 166. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AB 166 SENATORS
WIENER. AYE. WIENER. AYE
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
1313 TO 5. THAT BILL IS OUT FOR.
OH SORRY. 14 TO 4. OH, SORRY.
13. FOUR. 13 TO 4. THAT BILL IS
OUT. SORRY, WE'LL NEXT GO TO
ITEM 13 AB 168. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AB 168 SENATORS
WIENER. AYE. WIENER AYE. DURAZZO
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. 13. FIVE.
OKAY. 13 TO 5. THAT BILL IS OUT.
NEXT IS ITEM 14 AB 169. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AB 169
SENATORS WIENER. AYE WIENER AYE.
DOLLY DURAZZO. EGGMAN. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE THAT TAKES.
15. 15. 15. 15. ZERO. OKAY. THE
VOTE IS 15 ZERO. THE BILL IS
OUT, WE'LL NEXT GO TO ITEM
NUMBER 15, AB 170. PLEASE CALL
THE OPPOSITE MEMBERS. AB 170
SENATORS WIENER. AYE WIENER AYE.
DURAZZO. I DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
513. 413. FOR THE VOTE IS 13 TO
4. THE BILL IS OUT, WE'LL NEXT
GO TO ITEM 16, AB 171. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AB 171.
SENATORS WIENER AYE. WIENER AYE.
EGGMAN GROVE. AND THAT HAS BEEN
13 FOR.
SO 13. 13 TO. FOR THAT. BILL IS
OUT. NEXT IS ITEM 17, AB 173.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB 173 SENATORS WIENER AYE.
WIENER AYE. EGGMAN. 13 513 TO 5.
THAT BILL IS OUT, NEXT IS ITEM
NUMBER 18, AB 174. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AB 174
SENATORS WIENER AYE. WIENER AYE.
EGGMAN I HAVE 13 FOR 13 FOR THE
VOTE IS 13 TO 4. THAT BILL IS
OUT. AND THEN FINALLY AB. EXCUSE
ME. FINALLY IS ITEM NUMBER 19.
OH OH. MY MISTAKE. GROVE WAS 13.
YES. 14 FOUR. OKAY SO ON ITEM
NUMBER 18, THE VOTE IS 14 TO 4
AND THE BILL IS OUT. FINALLY,
IT'S ITEM NUMBER 19, AB 175.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AB 175. THE SENATORS WIENER AYE.
WIENER AYE. EGGMAN. 514 THREE
HAVE I HAVE A NON-VOTING.
15. THREE. 14. THREE. 14. THREE.
$5 AND NØ GROVE IS A NO. NO, I
JUST ADDED ANOTHER ONE. BUT
THERE'S 113, THEN MAYBE 14
MEMBERS. 14 WOKISM IS THE THIRD.
NO, I DON'T KNOW. FROM DOLLY IS
MY FIRST NAME. MY SECOND SMOKE.
I VOTED NO, BOTH.
14. THREE. IT'S 14 THREE. SORRY
14. THE VOTE IS 14 TO 3. AND
THAT BILL IS OUT. YES OKAY. I
WANT TO AGAIN THANK OUR AMAZING
BUDGET STAFF, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, THE LAO, AND EVERYONE
FOR COMING OUT TODAY AND ALL THE
HARD WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THIS
BUDGET FOR MONTHS BY OUR
MEMBERS, BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIRS AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO HAVE HELPED US
CRAFT THIS BUDGET WITH YOUR
FEEDBACK. AND WITH THAT, OUR
BUSINESS IS CONCLUDED AND THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW IS ADJOURNED.